oh it's oh you saw everything everything hello everybody hi hi hi hi hi welcome in who is who is for dinner here mom i don't know if this game has cannibalism anyways uh hello guys welcome to a harvester well not yet i didn't know if there was an intro so i didn't want to start the game yet you know what i mean i didn't know so i didn't want to start it and then there'd be like an intro and then you guys miss it so oh thank you i forgot the sensor what should we use as a sensor oh thank you thank you i forgot um in this game feel free to uh backseat because i heard it gets a little obtuse oh gosh hold on i'm so unprepared right now we could use this as a sensor
what if i turn him sideways don't ask why i just have this saved you know
emotional support snake or or we could use this as a sensor I think this actually might fit the vibe better
I think this one It's kind of like wet dog So it's like
But yeah I doubt it Just in case You know So this is an FMV uh or oh no i shouldn't show this i was gonna say i have a picture of my cat when he was a kitten but i don't know i don't want to dox him finally can't take your life after missing so many streams because we're like i'm lilac welcome back thank you so much for the for the aqua super thank you thank you thank you but um this is the fmv which is like with the real people um apparently it's like pretty crazy so we'll just have a little brief warning i suppose for the squeamish but um at the same time i don't think it's so bad that you know i think it's more goofy than anything so yeah freaky warning freaky warning um but we're just here to have a silly time so don't even worry about it what else was I gonna say uh uh I don't remember if you saw my desktop or like when I first switched over do you know how okay so I'm gonna explain a little bit how I've been playing these older games okay so I ended up getting a teeny tiny PC
like a teeny then I hook that with a with with a HDMI cord and then I hook that into my Elgato and so I have currently a a a keyboard in my lap and then I have two mice and so it's basically a dual streaming setup but also not at the same time because I only use it for these for these games wielding i'm dual wielding i tried it for what was that for uh actually hold on i'm seeing if there's anything on no there's nothing on my desktop it doesn't even have like uh here look at this it doesn't even have like a proper wallpaper but i did it for mystery of the druids too so yeah and so far it's been working well so
just like generic wallpaper so yeah yeah and i've i was uh making my schedule the other day and i was like i think i have pretty much everything i want to do this week but except for i kind of want like a like a you know i picked karaoke and i picked i picked vr chat but i wanted a game game and so um i was going through steam and i saw this and i was like Let's go.
Let's go.
So, yeah.
We will.
Oh, wait.
Let me pull it back up.
We will.
See how it goes.
Keep that wallpaper from Photoshop snake into it.
Tech wise, Minky.
No, no, no.
I feel like this is, I feel like honestly so many people have been telling me to get a dual setup.
But at the same time, I'm playing it.
through obs but it's a game i can play through obs i don't know having a second pc is such a hassle can't wait to see how many people are going to eat in this game i don't know if there's cannibalism but it just feels like there might be my birthday was the 16th may you get a late happy birthday happy late birthday kakuya happy birthday wow wow there's so many super ties and members thank you thank you thank you in my language your name means i lie What?
What?
Mint?
I'm not in English.
It's a plant.
If you're in the mood for more festive point-and-clicks, I recommend Grim Fandango.
Oh, yeah!
The Skelly game, right?
Okay.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, no!
English!
English desu!
Okay, oh, I just clicked use the wrong.
I just pressed play with the wrong mouse.
We're off to a good start.
Okay, play game.
Uh, I'm logged.
Oh, no.
Wait, I have to play it off Steam.
Okay, wait.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Wait, how do I play a game off Steam?
Uh-oh.
uh-oh uh-oh wait hold on uh-oh wait hold on I've never had to do that before wait do I have to re-buy it on GOG I don't want to do that hold on let me find the folder wait okay is there wait uh uh browse local file files.
Uninstall.
Okay, here I found it.
Can't run on your PC.
What about here?
Oh, I have nothing for ISO on here.
Oh, no.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, geez.
Okay, I'm going to GOG.
I'll just refund the Steam one, because I didn't play it.
I didn't think it would be a problem.
Okay, GOD.
I'm glad it is on GOD, right?
I hope so.
If not, okay, let's see.
Harvester.
Search.
The Steam one is broken anyway, is it really?
Oh, I didn't see any of that in the reviews.
I usually check for that.
Um,
oh, wait, I think GOG's mad at me because I didn't update it earlier.
I didn't update the client.
And it keeps yelling at me.
Oh, sorry, we couldn't load the data.
Why is this so scoped?
Um, okay, hold on.
Wait, oh no, this is so scoped.
scoffed wait why is it anything loading hold on let me close exit and then reopen sorry i'm not going to show you guys my desktop even if it's like a clean computer it's still too scary real gamers still have the an optical drive and a spindle of blank dvds just in case obviously i know i'm doing this so wrong sorry that you guys are stuck seeing the void
violent video games will ruin your meantime no i remember that time you told us you'd boot games okay no shut up murphy i'm gonna murder you okay it's not even my fault this time it is literally because steam doesn't like me being a vtuber and playing games at the same time so yeah i open up a game and i see if it works and it worked and then i try it when i'm when i when i I'm running all my stuff and it didn't work that's not my fault okay GOG updated and now everything is showing harvester I'm gonna murder you no don't even send hearts I'm mad at you trying to be like got them oh there it is game I meant hope you're having a good evening you too
me wait a second view in store wait how did i this game contains mature content recommended only for ages 17 plus it's a good thing i'm 19.
good thing i'm not 17 or else i wouldn't be able to play this clearly you need a third pc with windows 98 i think you're right okay bye now
Such a kidder.
I'm going to understand.
Everybody has been saying that in pre-chat, and I will understand eventually.
Okay, continue the payment.
Wait, how do I uninstall from?
Well, I can uninstall later.
Okay.
Uh,
continue the payment.
Guys, I have to go get my credit card.
Hold on, I'm going to put on some music.
Hold on, let me put on some music for you guys.
Wait, one second.
Wait.
My birthday is Wednesday, but you're off.
Can I get an early happy birthday?
Bro, happy birthday.
I don't know if you've been born towards the end of this game.
saves in a lot of slots or might be unbeatable.
Thank you for the warning.
I did hear a little bit, but I appreciate it so, so much.
Happy, happy birthday.
Real gamers memorize their CC number.
Okay, I'll say it out loud.
Wait, where's my music?
Where's my music?
Oh, maybe here.
Oh, wait.
No.
There.
Sorry.
I'll try to find my music.
Why can't I...
I give up.
I'm just going to put on this.
Oh.
Why can't I?
Why am I so indecisive right now?
Okay, let me go get my credit card.
It's not in this room.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god!
Pirate, that's the song I was looking for!
That's the song I wanted to play!
Wait, you have the title though.
You guys can listen to it.
Do you guys know that song?
It's the world famous!
Wait, I could get it.
I could get it.
This is En-Zekai-O-Nara contest.
Do you guys know this song?
Wait.
Oh no, wait, don't search...
Oh no, wait, oh no, wait, I need to put an Otova Citro, too.
I'm just getting a bunch of...
I'm getting recommended a bunch of videos of people farting.
No!
Okay.
That was so...
It was so loud.
It was so loud, I'm so sorry.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Okay, I'm back.
I'm putting in my credit card information.
Which one is the credit card?
Oh, this is it.
They're both the same color.
Pink.
Oh, I put it in!
Wait, where did I just type it?
I used the wrong keyboard!
Oh my god.
Am I...
Wait, okay, I didn't have chat open.
That would have been wild.
I'm crying.
Okay.
Where did it go?
Okay, there it is.
I'm typing it in.
Oh!
Check out.
Thank you.
Mint Phantom for buying.
Okay, thank you.
Install the game now.
Oh.
All games.
Wait, my games.
Owned games.
Harvester.
Install game.
We're installing the game.
Why?
I hope this version works.
Harvester funds.
Oh, thank you.
I think you should put it on your intro screen for 30 seconds.
And we all pretend like stream just started.
Can we do that?
Is it okay?
I'll pretend that everything's fine.
Yeah?
Wait, how long will it take to...
It's still installing.
This game is actually much bigger than I imagined it.
I guess it's all the FMVs.
Wait, is it loading?
Is it installing?
Wait, what's this mean?
Failed to connect to GOG server!
ReTroy!
No!
Oh my god!
Wait, it's actually...
It's not installing!
Oh my god!
Wait, it's actually...
Internet out!
What is how it happened?
Oh my god.
Wait.
I can't.
Amazon AWS down?
Oh.
It shouldn't be down.
I just bought something off of Amazon earlier.
Retry.
It gets to 2% it's like it's mocking me it gets to 2% and then says it can't connect this is the authentic scuff I look for guys I don't know what to do wait I actually don't know what to do GOG galaxy has a weird bug where you have to uninstall and then try to reinstall the game if you just bought the game oh wait wait wait wait installing 8% 9% oh it's It's going,
it's going, it's going!
It's going, it's going!
Ah!
Okay.
Alright, I restart stream.
Okay, we're almost at 50%, so, uh...
Okay, uh, redo!
Why isn't it showing up?
Oh, I hit it, that's why.
Welcome to Harvest, population 51!
Oh,
this is a stream where everything will go right and has been gone.
going right.
has and will go right.
Whoa, through the legs.
Why did the aspect ratio become so strange?
Let's have a fun time.
Whoa!
By reading this super chat, you have changed your luck.
Which way?
Love this game and I love you.
Really?
So much.
So many of you.
Well, that shit ends with directed by Hideo Kojima.
That would be the greatest twist of all time.
It would be so awesome.
That was the audio, by the way.
Looks like a Sims neighborhood.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I asked about the audio.
Like...
Okay.
Thank goodness you put on a shirt.
I was scared for a second.
He's humongous!
His room is also slanted.
Ah, here we are!
Harvester gameplay tips.
You can pick your friends, and you can pick your nose.
But you can't pick your friend's nose.
Okay!
Wait a second, I just realized the game is cut off, so...
There we go.
That should be...
I'll scoot over a little bit.
That should be good.
One second.
I'm redoing my setup.
Um.
Yeah, we'll keep the tips on.
Yes, I can.
Come here, Minto.
No!
Right-clicking on some objects in inventory show a close-up of that object.
on weapons and inventory activates and deactivates them press escape to bring up menu options you can combine objects into new objects by clicking and dragging them on one another Bankerton thank you so much for that gift sound levels can be adjusted in the options menu Wow they're actually sound levels screen to dark try adjusting the gamma in the options menu check your photo in the inventory screen it will get worse as you take more damage wait I want to see look for special items that will will restore your health after finding required items during the day night will be the time of mischievous adventure double click the mouse the left mouse button on an exit to go through instantly okay well use the right mouse button to attack an opponent that's some of these are kind of important I feel left click on your character or press I to view inventory left click on an object to grab it right click to put it in inventory a penny saved is hardly worth the effort thank you very much okay
they couldn't get a better picture of you buddy i like how he's like moonwalking smooth criminal
caught mid sneeze Oh!
Oh!
Middle punch, low punch.
High punch, middle punch, low punch.
So good!
Paper doll by the Mills brother sits on the turntable.
It doesn't...
Okay, it does examine the clarinet.
Obviously some fat high school girl left it there.
What if they draw...
Wait, put him on MS Paint to slow damage.
Why did he say that like that?
A handful of faded hardbacks litter the lower shelf.
Is this your bed?
The mattress is speckled with odd stains.
A pair of plastic binoculars with the lenses melted to the table.
Not the acne medicine!
An empty acne medicine container!
Can we take it?
Nope.
Oh my
god.
A photo of a beautiful girl, blonde, about 17 years old.
She can't play this game.
Examine the pinup.
A sexy pinup.
Woo-wee!
Yeah!
The official Dust Bowl Basketball.
Autographed by GPL.
I want to take some stuff.
An empty trash can so clean you could eat from it.
This dresser drawer is unlocked.
We'll open it.
Oh, there we go.
We've got a quarter.
Date of 1952.
Take that.
Okay, never mind.
Wait.
Pick up the quarter.
Ah, I got it.
I got it.
The protagonist is the true horror already.
We love games like that, though, don't we?
I tried searching Minto instead of Mint, and apparently there's a small town in Canada called Minto.
My sunglasses?
As of yet, the future isn't so bright.
Yeesh.
This game looks so goosebumps, I'm having childhood flashbacks.
A pen.
Shoe marks are visible at the end of this ballpoint pen.
Pick it up.
Okay, we'll take it with us.
Anything else in here?
I like the please wait.
He's got the cuck chair in his own room.
A cheap folding chair such as you find at swap meets bingo parlors and other religious gatherings.
Seven flannel shirts accompanied with matching blue jeans are hanging neatly in the closet.
Oh, he's got a plant and everything.
A recently watered plastic...
Why did you walk...
Wait.
This game is silly.
One of your typical wall clocks.
I like looking at everything.
Oh no.
I'm a looker, you guys.
P-47 Thunderbolt!
A 148th scale P-47 Thunderbolt with a broken propeller.
Ah.
And he's got a P-51 Mustang.
There's a town in Australia called Minto, too.
Apparently it's not very nice.
Aw.
What?
What do you mean?
Okay.
Let's leave.
The walking is so...
Why is he standing there like that?
A stunning depiction of the earth made of paper mache.
Who are you?
Leave me alone, Steve, or I'll tell Mom on you.
What other?
What can I say?
Wait, I could say whatever I want?
Stupid.
what dummy say what say what cowboy say what mom mom's in the kitchen and if you bug me I'll call her look I just do you know me wish I didn't cuz then you wouldn't be my brother and I'd have your room and all the presents at Christmas anyway because you're a lousy rat you're my brother no duh what listen I don't mean to uh bug you but I can't seem to remember anything will you please just tell me who you are mom Steve is bugging me Steve you hang alone right now say what lousy rat why am I a rat what did I do to you you went and got all mushy on that girl and now you're lighting out on me well but that's the way you're gonna be then you can drop dead this kid is like six years old who's the girl I don't know what girl you're talking about all summer it's been Stephanie this and Stephanie I gotta blow my nose now you don't remember you think I'm dumb or something no I just can't remember anything like I said well you better remember quick cuz the weddings in two weeks what leave me
alone so I can watch TV I'm getting married what's on TV that's a weird-looking television come to think of it this whole place looks totally retro what do you mean retro all TVs look alike sure basically but this is one old-fashioned clunker old-fashioned it's brand new yeah but look at the tube where's the remote control where's there the tube what's that I now that I think about it I can't remember and what was that you said about retro No,
retro.
It means...
Oh, man, I know what I mean.
Uh-oh.
That everything here is wrong.
But I can't picture the difference.
Then shut up and quit bugging me.
It's so wide.
I want some trouble shut.
Congratulations on the marriage.
Oh, he's got that ultra-wide screen.
It just... it takes up like this amount.
Have you noticed that your show isn't black and white?
What else?
Color?
a TV?
Well, I think I've seen a color television before.
Have not.
What did it run on a TV?
41.9.
Look at that.
Your mother lets you watch this stuff?
Sure.
This is part of history.
Part of history.
In America, great.
And besides, blood and guts are needed.
Blood and guts.
Oh, you're right.
That is really neat.
We could be an ultra psycho, or we could say little kids shouldn't watch violence.
Yeah, we'll say it's Nito.
I'm glad you're catching on, Steve.
You're not too bad.
Well, lousy rat.
The audio is so...
Okay, bye.
Good.
Final.
Oh, my gosh.
Pendulum-driven cuckoo clock with the cuckoo oddly absent.
Oh!
Fine bone china?
Gleams from the mahogany shelves.
don't be afraid to grab a walk through the puzzles are weird thank you i've heard that yeah thank you thank you let's see what else we got newspaper a box full of newspaper that will help us though right yeah pick up the newspaper oh i didn't mean to leave no go back in pick up the newspaper Paper.
Or not.
Mom.
Wait, there's a baby!
A newborn is sleeping soundly.
How old am I?
This is my mom and she has a newborn.
Say the F word to the mom.
There's a unique dialogue.
Oh, cool.
Expertly embroidered old-fashioned wall plaque.
These cookies are hot out of the oven.
Well, hello there.
How about some cookies?
There's plenty of rejects in the trash.
Who are you?
That's a fine way to talk to your mother.
You're my mother?
That's right.
Though sometimes I get treated like the hired help around here.
I don't remember you.
Of course you don't.
Until you need your socks washed.
No, you don't understand.
I can't remember where I am or even who I am.
Landsake, stop your joshing, won't you?
Yeah.
Steve, I thought you'd grow up a little after graduation.
I only hope that new job will plant your feet on the ground.
So that's my name.
Steve.
Your name will be M-U-D.
Mudd!
The...
Listen.
This may sound strange.
Kitchen is...
But I've lost my memory.
So loud.
Do you believe me?
Well, you always were a kidder, Steve.
I'm serious.
Sure.
And next, you'll be telling me you don't remember Hank and your little...
little sister oh gosh okay there's so much I don't know Hank but my little sister you always were a kidder when did I graduate four months ago as if you could forget that what college college a high school diploma is all you need to get a job and besides you can't marry Stephanie if you're going to waste your time going to college 18 years old and you're just now getting your first job What the?
Better late than never.
I guess we can thank Stephanie for that.
What, Stephanie?
Is that my girlfriend?
And just who is Stephanie?
Don't you dare toy with that sweet girl.
If you started on her with all this amnesia poop, she'll think her fiance is having second thoughts about the wedding.
I don't know.
Wait, okay, hold on.
I'm gonna save.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
You know how he gets.
This is this menu.
Save game.
Wow, they gave us 25 saves.
Save.
Right?
Did it save?
Did that work?
I can't quite tell.
Save?
Oh, I'm stuck in this.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck down here.
Oh, I have to give it a name!
Uh...
I...
I am Steve.
It's not Steven, sorry.
Okay.
Um...
What else we got in here?
I am Steven.
Oh, I messed it up!
Oh, I told you I'm busy, Steve.
Why don't you talk to Hank or go next door and visit Stephanie or go get an early start on your new job?
If I say...
Guys, this is something that I need to censor if I say the...
If I say F word to her.
Flint and Steel is the F word.
Don't look up what happened to the actor who plays Steve.
Um, I think...
Okay, I definitely saw some people...
Saying that in pre-chat, I think you guys need to learn what the Streisand effect is.
If you...
I would have never looked up this guy.
I don't really care about the actor.
I would have never had a reason if everybody in the chat wasn't like, don't!
It's like, don't play this game at 3 a.m.
What does that mean?
The Streisand effect?
so basically barbara strizam was just like they what okay i might get the story wrong but her house was on like google or something and she was like stop looking at my house don't you dare look at my house and was trying to get her house taken down and and it made everyone be like oh so why well now i need to know why you want me to go look or you don't want me to look at your house.
Yeah, trying to hide something will bring more attention to it.
Yeah, if you come in, you're just like...
Or you're like, Hey, don't do this thing.
But yeah, whatever.
Um...
I was listening to the pre-chat craziness on the way home.
What did it say?
Good job fighting through the craziness.
Thank you!
Okay, what was it?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, so...
So I don't need to censor.
We can just say...
We can just say it.
Can I say that?
Will it work?
Stop speaking nonsense, dear.
Oh, do I just say the regular word?
It's like when Mint tells us not to call her Q.
Just the word.
What a thing to say to your mother.
Was that an invitation now that your father is out of action?
Um...
I didn't mean it.
Wait.
YouTube's gonna take down my channel.
YouTube's gonna take down my channel!
I'm kind of scared though.
What if I said... I'm kind of scared... I'm so curious about saying yes.
But I'm scared.
Press one.
Maybe later, dear.
Right now, I have housework to do.
So you can watch if you want.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
You know how he gets.
She just changes it so fast.
The subject.
Mom?
It's full of junk mail bills and bake sale flyers.
Is this Jimmy?
Jimmy James!
Hey, Steve, I'm Jimmy James.
Remember me?
I guess not.
Hey, how come you haven't been putting the paper out for me in the morning?
Hey, Steve, I'm Jimmy James.
You remember me?
Why'd they hire an actual child for this game?
Sweet home, Alabama.
Hey, Steve, I'm Jimmy James.
Uh...
supposed to i got better things though i'm we're steve the jerk i don't want to be a jerk to jimmy james i think he's cute yeah we'll try to remember will you never mind how'd you expect a working joe to make an honest living you don't put the paper out i'm out of a job okay so what you don't get paid for picking up papers anyway this isn't a building burnt down what the heck else am i supposed to do listen start putting that paper out and everything will be jake okay that's That's all I want.
That and a pair of sneakers.
Sh-neakers.
I'm in this mood every day, as worn holes in mine.
Say, you got any spare sneakers?
You got any spare sneakers?
Uh, nope, sorry.
Oh, gee whiz.
Look, you funny.
I'd be willing to trade you for him.
Something really neat of.
Think about it.
See you later, alligator.
In a while, crocodile.
Wait, there's a frisbee up there.
A dayglow Lima Space Disc.
Stuck on the roof.
What's wrong with the air conditioner?
An army surplus air conditioner.
Okay.
Can I...
Oh, I can leave.
The way he walks.
Whoa!
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
Where did I just go?
Oh, what's happening?
I think I went to the military base on accident.
This air...
Wait, these aircraft...
appear to be well maintained um colonel buster oh who goes there uh they tell me my name is steve all right this section 21 keep your distance son i wouldn't want to have to blow your head off that makes two of us so you're the amnesiac huh how do they know just enough a draft dodging ploy the way i see it but at least you're not alien you see their ships every now and then sometimes swell bags one in the woods who are you Colonel Buster Monroe commander of the harvest nuclear missile installation keeping America safe from those that would die a flag red white and pink don't say these are nuclear missiles don't say pink right they are every one of them ready to rain death on the Ruskies all I got to do is hit the button and blammo blammo a place of vodka goes through the roof along with the vodka well i suppose you have you know safeguards against accidents safeguards oh don't be such a weak sister there are no safeguards this is the 50s the 50s then you have sole control of the why is
he sitting on the ground that's right been in charge here since w W-2.
W-2.
When I got my lower torso shot off in the war.
Those penny wastes in Washington wanted to stick me behind a desk.
To hell with that.
They owed me.
I left my legs in Dusseldorf.
I thought he was sitting crisscross applesaued.
Of course, they felt that after the trauma of having to crawl from Germany to England trailing my intestines behind me, I was too emotionally unstable to continue in the military.
yet here you are that's why they gave me this nice cushy job and put me in charge of the nuclear missiles okay wow um uh we'll come back i didn't even mean to come here remember duck and cover duck and cover yes sir okay um hold on i was trying to like see okay so there's the lodge our house general store post office barber shop this is just the the nuclear missile base in our in our calm little neighborhood here i guess oh oh see there is more up the pots dam residence abandoned house johnson residence shady oaks mortuary cemetery oh my god this place is huge wayward hotel fire station police station newspaper building uh edna's diner tv Gain Memorial School.
Oh, sorry.
The meatplat.
Okay.
Yeah, it did say population 51.
Um.
Okay.
The meatplat.
Whatever that kid Stevie's gone.
I think this place is a little cooked.
Okay.
Well, her mom is strange.
Everything is strange.
Everyone keeps telling me to save.
We'll keep saving on I.
I'm Steve.
Jimmy.
What did I call him?
Jimmy James.
Tall girl Vanessa, welcome to Mamba Chef.
Thank you.
Well, I guess we just leave.
What else do I have?
Wait.
Oh, do I need to put the paper out?
It wouldn't let me re-grab it.
Let me try.
Oh, don't worry.
I'm going to do multiple saves, you guys.
Don't worry.
I understand when you guys tell me to do saves, it should be multiple.
But...
Oh, no, it doesn't let me.
Hmm.
But just because we didn't do anything, that's why I saved it again.
Air-conditioned.
The tired air conditioner weezes in the unseasonal heat.
Yum.
asparagus tips too for 49 cents harvest bake sale this friday in the school gym okay who's this guy and demand wait oh he's too busy working to notice you tape and broken glass obviously a professional break
let's go in
whoa hi free copies made Wow, a free copy, a copier in the 50s?
Empty barrels that smell like pickles.
Shoddy old TV missing the VHF knob.
It's in my thank you!
This is Phelps General Store.
So who would that make me?
Maybe you need to go back to Game Memorial and have Miss Whaley teach you about logic.
Ooh!
I'm fuzzy on a lot of things these days.
gone shah you always were a kid or steve i'm serious i need some help well they say a sharp blow to the head is a good thing for amnesia in which case i'd recommend miss waley again then again they say a good scare can jog the memory in which case i'd advise you to visit the sergeant at arms over at the lodge have a lot that man gives me the willies speaking of willies how's your father don't know haven't seen him care to buy anything today uh yes please let's see what you got just point to whatever you want i'm a little hard of hearing okay oh the shelf contains a variety of odd items for sale oh we could get we can get the adult magazine we could get a wrench we could get coffee We could get...
Soup cans.
We could get...
Uh, tape?
Um...
An adult magazine for 25 cents!
Wait!
That's what I have!
I took it from my...
Wait, I got it from my drawer!
How much are the coffee?
A cow is bleeding a robust coffee on these harvest blend coffee can like wait cans of soup or possibly rat poison wait slightly used wrench you must pay miss Phelps but it doesn't say how much it is this is only 25 cents get me out of here oh exit give me hello Steve care to buy anything today yes please just point to whatever you want I'm a little hard of hearing And hold on,
before we do that, though, we'll make a new save.
Okay, save.
Can I please have the booty magazine?
May I please purchase the booty magazine?
Can I please have the magazine with the bright, with the blushing...
from red cheeks.
How do I give her the money?
Wait, hold on.
If I click my inventory, okay, we got the quarter.
Use quarter on Ms. Phelps.
Ah-ha!
The only thing a quarter will buy you is an adult magazine.
A girly magazine?
Why, Steve, I'm surprised at you.
I'd expect that sort of thing from Deputy Loomis, but never from you.
He's always coming in here, ogling the girly magazines behind my counter.
Darned if I'd sell him one though.
I know his wife for heaven's sakes.
Oh Well, will you sell me one?
Certainly will Steve.
That kind of interest is healthy for a young fellow Stairs him away from being a fireman.
What's wrong with being a fireman?
Water cooler dead roaches and bits of arid grit coat the water cooler's bone-dry reservoir.
Ew Wait, so now I have a magazine.
I'll see Let's check it out.
Let's read it in public.
Come here.
Come here, Steve.
All right.
Wait, how do I, uh, I think it's right click.
Dang it.
Oh, I do have the newspaper!
Let's go back home.
I'll put the newspaper out, I suppose.
Somewhere.
Well, that didn't work.
Oh, okay.
Okay?
Okay.
Just kidding.
Alright.
Let's go to...
Where did she say?
There was like some guy.
Let's just go everywhere.
Okay.
41% off packing peanuts.
Nice.
Be a pal and put the magazine out.
Well.
Examine the woman.
A blind woman is trying to read her...
His mailbox is...
seem hardly used yes I need some help mr.
postmaster Boyle what can I do for you today assorted colors I'd like a lodge application oh wait what is that for sorry youngster we're out of applications right now come on you must have one around here somewhere well I do have the master but you can't write on that and I only make copies once a month on the button,
regulars, clockwork.
Adjust my seat.
Okay.
Oh, a job.
Come on, I won't kill you to make a lousy copy.
Wait, we can do it for free at the general store.
It's not the effort, son.
It's the principle.
He's angry at me.
We must adhere to our standards.
They're all that stand between civilization and chaos.
I'm sorry.
You'll just have to come back in a month, same as anyone else.
And even then, I can't guarantee you'll get an application.
The line is always long, and there are never enough to go around.
It's very important that I get in quickly.
That's what they all say.
Why?
Post-Mester Boyle, I'll just die if I don't get into the lodge.
I can't make an exception, young man.
It just wouldn't be right.
Uh, lodge.
I certainly don't wish to discourage you from joining, young man.
That's just what you should be striving for.
But I can't break the rules for you.
trying you'll get in eventually wait a second hold on next time you post don't forget the zip code let's let's let's bribe them that interests me not at all young man i see okay let's go get let's go get play girl wait play boy is for boys
Exit.
Here's a man of principal here.
What's at the barbershop?
This nice little trees here.
Okay.
Where's the sheep's...
Was that an alien?
Oh, yeah.
An unfortunate extraterrestrial who journeyed hundreds of light years to wind up mounted on a barber's wall.
Okay.
Sheep.
I mean, I meant, oh, except for its occasional hairball cough, it's hard to tell if the sheep is alive or not.
Pokemon music.
He must be a volunteer fireman on the side.
True!
Look at that.
Sculpture made of solidified moose and sticky hairspray.
This lovely mannequin is a work of art.
There's so much going on in here.
It's a picture of Mr. Pastroli as a young buck.
I like how the sheep is part of the OST.
Fargo, thank you so much for the fact it did.
Thank you.
Okay, we'll start with Mr. Pastorelli.
Mr. Pastorelli doesn't respond.
Not understanding English.
No!
What about you, Mr. Swell?
Howdy, Steve.
Howdy.
Howdy back, Mr. Pete Swell, Steve.
Don't you pull my old leg now?
What takes place inside of every barber shop?
Change your mind about that aluminum siding.
What are you talking about?
What?
I really think you should talk your father into buying some.
He can afford it.
And I can't stress enough the value on some really fine aluminum siding.
Yeah, his eyes are.
It keeps it warm in the summer, cool in the winter, and it keeps out the shoes.
Pastorelli oughta look into some, but I can't get him to understand the word I say.
this is so bad the sheep I'm curious about the sheep can't no sorry I clicked too fast he just said can't aluminum side a pastorelli click pastorelli's a rubed from way back ask Clem Parsons how he followed up with oh I can type it in I could fix it for him,
but he just won't listen.
Cheap.
Wait.
Sometimes the clicking is a little, you know.
Can't understand why Pastorelli keeps that nasty thing in here.
Must remind him of the pastures in Italy.
Kind of like why I keep wrenches under my pillow.
So as I can dream about plumbing.
Blumbing?
Well.
I've seen the end coming for the aluminum siding game, so I took a mail course and learned how to be a plumber.
Now, there's a business that never lets up.
You'd be surprised what people flushed down the toilet.
That is so true.
Goodbye.
Nice to see you again, Steve.
He was nice.
Mr. Parsons.
Hello there, youngster.
They say them aliens I was telling you about.
Well, they came back last night.
the field how come i never seen none of them saucers clams them aliens is widely picked them aliens the intergalactic void without learning the trick look at his face you know what castorelli did yesterday he gets an alarm system to protect his pole only he don't know how to rig it so now it's all arrived his pole why that barber's pole he is is his pride and joy Brought it all the way over from Italy,
wrapped all special-like.
Ooh, oh, that's so cute.
Colored glass with some bulbs stuck up in it.
Buddy thinks it's to be all-in-all.
Installed that alarm system just to protect it.
Though who in tarnation did want to steal a worthless piece of junk like that?
The aliens, the aliens.
Maybe an alien, friend?
Oh, Pete, don't be ignorant.
Them aliens don't give a fig for no colored glass.
build spaceships they can't make a bad gum barber pole crazy hit don't know nothing about science the science wait what about more what about aliens aliens well son the ways of the alien is a specialized area would craft the known thank you so much for the fight what you got to remember is your average alien is smarter than your average human so you got to be extra careful building you're blind if you want a bag one you hunt aliens son after nailing an alien you can never go back to quail what you think you can get one of those that has swapped me you know when you like line you're blind with lead to fool their sensing machines lady eating the aliens preferably in the woods around the nuclear base oh they love messing around out there why not wait outside your field,
Clem.
Wait for them to come a carving.
Oh, they do their crop doodles with zap guns you darn full, don't you know nothing?
Besides, ain't no place to put the blind out in the field.
Now, you listen to Clem Parsons if you want to tag an unearthly being.
I see.
They cross the void, wondering what lies beyond, all the time not knowing that what awaits them is buckshot.
The aliens face looks like when I'm like messing around in the Sims and I make their their mouth really really small so what about alarm system I feel like we need to know the alarm system if we have to break in here eventually maybe probably pasty rarely shelled out for an alarm system all right but he's too cheap to hire an electrician to hook her up dang idiot crosswired it through the fire sprinkler and the alarm goes off it sets the sprinkler oh no tarnation tarnation aliens looking for intelligent life ought to stay away from this shop sure enough oh it's so mean okay bye anytime steve what is this behind them i'm trying clem parsons took this rare photograph of an extraterrestrial okay this is not what i expected of the barber shop but um very cool After playing Mass Effect,
it really isn't the same after you've nailed one of them aliens.
Are you also eating aliens?
The Lodge!
This is the place we're trying to get in.
Okay.
We didn't really do anything, so I'll just keep saving.
Only initiates may enter the Hall of the Order of the Harvest.
moon did you say something i did not speak but my mind touched yours telepathy but how only those who seek enlightenment warrant my attention do you hunger for true knowledge yes i'd like to join the lodge there are always obstacles to the path you must First,
you fill out an application to be considered for initiation into the mysteries.
Paperwork?
Yeah, paperwork?
Members of the Order are privy to many hidden truths.
You have telepathy and you're making me do paperwork?
They know what the trees whisper to the wind to make it howl.
The worm knows as it squirms in a rotting leg.
They know what you've found.
gotten wait you you know i think i can live without no no you're talking about my amnesia when you find the truth will be revealed to you when you possess the truth you will know what you knew and if anything remains forgotten then it was never worth the knowing okay interesting looks like it looks as ancient as the building itself I think you've got,
like, a rat problem.
Red eyes gleam with eerie malevolence from the darkness.
I could just sneak in, probably.
And then we got this pipe.
Alarming green sludge oozes from the drain.
The masonry looks as though it may be from the dark ages.
Okay.
What else we got?
Pottsdem.
I'm just gonna enter this house.
The glass is so clear, the reflection makes it difficult to see.
What was that?
Did you guys hear that?
It sounded like gunshots.
The garage needs a new paint job.
Mr. Potsdam.
Wait, what?
A funerary earned is the cabinet's sole occupant.
The man of the house.
Squeezing his meat.
Almost made of leather.
Polyester's music is really just...
Mrs. Potts, um...
Hello, Steve.
Have you flossed today?
You look just like my mom, except for the hair.
Oh, Stephanie, yeah, I want to meet Stephanie.
Well, Stephanie is grounded, Steve.
What?
Why?
I'm sure I don't know.
Mr. Poston has sent her to a room, and in her room she'll stay until Mr. Poston says otherwise.
Probably until the wedding.
What if I type mom?
Sorry, I didn't catch that.
Okay, never mind.
Tell me about this wedding.
Well, it's set for three weeks.
We're holding it over at Shady Oaks, Mr. Moynihan's funeral parlor.
A funeral parlor!
Now, I know it's not a very romantic place, but there's nowhere else to hold it.
What is this music?
Everything is overlapping.
Uh...
Mr. Moynihan runs the Wayward Hotel and the Shady Oaks funeral parlor.
It's rumored he has connections with the lodge.
But the order keeps that kind of thing secret so mr.
Paxton has tried to get him to put in a good word for his lodge application but so far the lodge we need to know more about the lodge what can you tell me about the lodge yeah just that they're exclusive and secretive if you're curious you want to pick up a lodge application at the post office and take it over to the sergeant at arms isn't that a thought.
Forget Mr. Podstum.
If you became a member of the order, we could hold the wedding inside the lodge.
My, wouldn't that be lovely?
What is going on so far?
You mustn't be too hard on Mr. Podstum, Steve.
He's a disappointed man.
This money returns my bank account tomorrow.
I could be sure I was dreaming.
No!
He has a new application in, though, so keep...
Keep your fingers crossed.
If he joins the lodge, you and Stephanie can have your wedding in the Chapel of Love.
Rather than over at Moynihan's place.
The Chapel of Love.
Love.
Sorry, I didn't catch that.
If I also say the...
Give my regards to your parents.
The F word to her, will she...
Stephanie's mom.
Stephanie's mom save yeah we're gonna try it most people won't react that's okay oh dear come to see Stephanie have you yes please she's upstairs oh go right on up just remember she's grounded until the wedding so we could see her but okay sorry I didn't catch that okay bye give my regards to your parents ice box the Bushes are preventing it from opening.
You can't even use the door?
Okay.
Exit.
The entire kitchen has a minty fresh look and scent!
Minty fresh!
Me!
We'll talk to him in a second.
Let's go talk to our girl.
Examine the thing.
It's, you know, one of those things.
The closet door won't budge.
What's in here?
Wait, wait, wait.
Before we talk to her.
Why are we so small?
Before we were so huge and now we're so small.
What is this music?
Is Stephanie and Haley?
I don't know.
A thin layer of hair coats virtually every inch of ceramic.
Nasty.
Operate the toilet.
Wait.
What's the picture?
She's purdy.
What the hell?
The picture on the wall is hanging a bit crooked.
It's covered with what appears to be toothpaste.
Wow, they don't clean!
Oh my gosh, we're in our girlfriend's room.
This is huge, you guys.
This is huge.
Who are you?
What are you doing in my room?
She doesn't know.
so you're the one Steve isn't it she's so cute I mean you don't know me I mean I don't know anyone I don't remember anything how many times do I have to say it just one Stephanie because I can't remember a damn thing either oh really oh God I thought it was just me you're not alone can you tell me what's going on here those people downstairs have locked me in my room they say I'm grounded wedding those people wait amnesia maybe my amnesia isn't total after all you're familiar to me like we've met before in another life you say God maybe we really do the music stop maybe we were together and the same thing happened to both of us an axis something neither of us has bumps on our heads if that's what you're getting at have you been able to remember anything else I mean anything at all well I have had these recurring dreams just fragments really kicking them hearts strange abstract images liquid chrome probably just a dream well have you thought about how to escape harvest oh it came back
What is...
I'm examining his figure.
My man, look at the Laura Croft booty on this guy.
It's so sharp.
The wedding is only three weeks away.
Not much time to get to know each other, is it?
Uh, suddenly the idea of a wedding doesn't seem so bad.
Wait, am I into her or not?
she's like okay hold on he's one two three he's about say like 10 lips high oh that's maybe generous but she's probably like 15.
do you like blondes yeah into it thanks but I wouldn't marry anyone with things you know as they are tall clean yeah well they can't force us to go through with it if it comes down to it we just think it's more less about him being short in just the proportions of everything too many people are determined that we get hitched why potstam wants the meat your father promised him your parents want to force you to settle down mrs potstam wants to have the wedding in the lodge me i just want to escape
escape harvest is a prison steve oh yeah don't forget that yeah yeah i think you're right yeah these people are just eccentric but they are of course i'm right i don't think we did the lodge yet everything in harvest seems to revolve around this This order of the Harvest Moon.
They're responsible for this insane fake sale that's coming and for the Harvest Blood Drive too.
When people talk about the lodge, it's always in this hushed, reverent tone.
Yeah.
Oh, what's happening?
Mom keeps telling me that women can't join.
But she keeps pressuring me to get you to join.
Oh.
She's not the only one who wants me to sign on with the lodge.
That's probably the worst thing you could do.
a trap i think all of harvest is a trap yeah that's true maybe joining the lodge is the way out look why not explore the town a little i can't get out of here but if i could that's what i do maybe you can figure out what's happening here without going anywhere near the lodge you're really afraid of the lodge aren't you i look at that building all lit up at night and i get scared same cutscene.
I mean, look at the damn thing.
Oh.
Seem like a harmless bunch of masons to you.
She's so pretty.
Okay, bye.
Come back and visit me soon.
Okay.
Let's go talk to her papa.
With the alien music.
There he is.
My future son-in-law.
And how's he doing today?
What brings him to the Potsdam House sold.
Huh?
Uh-huh?
I came over to see...
Wait, what if I say I've also lost my memory?
What a card.
Would I kid about something like that?
Why won't you believe me?
Well, you always were a kidder, Steve.
You rather just telephone dust about your lady's shenanigans.
Isn't that right, Mrs. Potsdam?
Sure did, Mr. Potsdam.
You little rascal.
Little rascal.
Imagination's a swell thing to have in small amounts.
man needs to keep his feet on the ground especially if he's getting married tell me is your father feeling better is he going back to the slaughterhouse slaughterhouse oh that must be the meat place um amnesia this is sick I'm supposed to marry this Stephanie and I don't even know who she is it's so loud why is there like a breeze in this house but don't go scaring me like that it's so windy in here now look is a commitment you're going to marry my daughter will be one happy family and your dad's going to give me all the meat I want right right oh why is he love meat he has the meat on the wall what's what is the meat made of the meat aliens like why is Stephanie grounded well don't look at me Mrs. Podstam wants Stephanie to study hard for her finals if it was up to me you could go straight upstairs but you know the little woman you'll have to ask her permission to see Stephanie oh well I did sorry Steve the last thing I should have talked to him first my bad and your father before the
wedding not with the meat at stake you will remind your dad about the meat won't you I think that sound is TV static I think he's watching straight up TV static oh he might be the meat I need to know the of any decent society.
Everyone needs at least three servings of red meat a day.
And anyone who says otherwise is a commie.
And once you're married to Stephanie, I'll be part of the family too.
And your father will give me all the meat I want.
Kind of makes up for not getting into the lodge.
Oh my god.
I haven't seen my father He's locked in a room Wait, he's locked in a room He's not going to die, is he?
Like I said, I don't know That woman mom Tends to him herself Well, next time you've seen Be sure to tell him that I said hello And tell him that I'm praying For his speedy recovery
I can't hear you over the The sound of the If I see...
Greasy waves.
Like ASMR.
If he dies, then who's going to take over the slaughterhouse?
Who's going to tend to the meat?
I guess as a son...
The meat!
You take over.
Right?
I can't hear you.
Slaughterhouse?
Did I ask?
I can't imagine a better job than working in a slaughterhouse.
A slaughterhouse?
I think working in a slaughterhouse might be cool.
Okay.
Sure, it'd be just dandy.
And you can't argue with success.
Everyone in harvest gets their meat from your dad.
There's a fun scene in the bathroom?
Me, wait, wait.
Oh, sure.
Oh, my God.
Cutting animals open may not be much fun.
Reaching into their bodies and yanking out the bloody guts, intestines dangling and slapping against you.
The smell of death and shit in your nostrils all the time.
those are all definite comms but once you're done your guts have been washed oh my god what was that you left with me scared me my ears I literally jumped okay bye I don't want to talk to you anymore
something in the bathroom what can I do Oh.
God, that scared me.
I think I examined everything in here though.
Oh, medicine cabinet.
Reeks of various toiletries.
Uh, a window affords a spectacular view of aluminum siding.
Oh, the aluminum siding!
Quads of used tissue.
Ew.
Fix it?
Oh!
You just...
Okay.
The music?
It's a start?
The music was so like...
Where?
None of the music in this game fits the situation.
It's an awesome...
I'm sorry, ma'am.
Who... who are you wearing that for?
She's just... she's just wanting to look sexy all by herself?
Yeah, I can't help that the game is stretched.
I'm sorry.
Unfortunately.
It did that on its own.
Oh.
Let a girl play dress up.
You're so right.
Wow.
She was like...
Was that a chicken?
It's impossible to prepare anyone for this game.
I feel...
Wait, is it...
Oh no, I thought it was night time for a second.
Abandoned house.
What's here?
Ooh, spooky!
Are those flies?
The car...
The old car is a perfect nesting ground for wasps.
Oh, wasps.
The rusty gutter is the perfect nesting ground for wasps.
The attic window is a perfect nesting ground for wasps.
The overhang is a perfect nesting ground for wasps.
It is not the perfect...
Wait, I can go in.
Oh.
Oh, there's wasps.
Okay, maybe this is the only time the music has been...
The icebox is sealed shut with wasp nests.
Bees!
The Mint Cafe is a perfect nesting ground for wasps.
For wisps.
A wasp nest.
A rather colorful picture of a wasp.
What is going on in this game?
Oh, I can't walk anymore.
Tetsua Crum.
It's not often that I get visitors.
I am Tetsua Crum.
call me the wasp woman.
A pejorative, no doubt.
Born of fear and a poverty of imagination.
I don't understand.
The politics of honey.
The Judeo-Christian rights of sacrifice and conventional taboos against unbridled pleasure are all responsible for the prejudice against wasps.
What?
Wasps?
Wasps.
Um, pleasure?
Yes, a great deal of pleasure.
The wasp is a sensual being, not a laborer, hedonistic instead of industrial.
Some think them quick to anger.
In truth, they are easily swayed to ecstasy.
They penetrate your flesh, and the muscular contractions in their thorax as they pump venom
contractions of ejaculation each painful welt an act of love
this lady fuses your personas what are you what is that supposed to mean um regard
the wasps i'm not sure what to say about i have no comment wasps produce nothing for others but only for themselves wasps spill nests and more wasps nothing more they spread into ease and addicts not to make honey for supermarkets gonna do a great tumbler in six years perpetuating their own agenda growing stealthily i was stung by a lot of wasps the most relentless of insects that's the that's the lodge oh my god oh my god Oh my god!
Even the wasps?
What does this mean for the pain in Metal Gear Solid 3?
When a bee stings, it rips itself apart and dies for its audacity.
This appeals to those raised worshiping a god that demands sacrifice and atonement.
But the wasp is promiscuous.
Promiscuous.
They are not as sympathetic.
to the masses because they don't die when they sting yeah they live to sting another day and they take pleasure from it but what if i say be a triviality this super chat is the perfect destined ground for wasps the pain what do i say um i think yeah i think i I'm just going to go.
Bye.
Wow.
That.
Let's.
Okay.
Wait a second.
One second before we talk to Mr. Johnson.
I want to go back home.
Because they said that my dad is in a room.
I want to see.
Oh, the master bedroom.
maybe here the master bedroom door is firmly locked if I talk to my mom I told you I'm busy Steve why don't you talk to Hank or go next door and visit Stephanie or go get an early start on your new job what's my new job what's my job that's right a job oh your father has everything set up at the meat plant after your honeymoon with Stephanie you'll start out as a butcher in the slaughterhouse just like anybody else don't expect any favors just because you're the boss's son okay don't forget to put the papers out for jimmy you know how he gets that's the true horror my mom telling me to get a job
i part of me wants to go to this to the meat house because i'm so curious now the meat plant But there's also some...
We've been kind of just making our way around town, you know?
Nah, we'll go to the meat.
Meat plant.
What is that?
Oh.
Red brick building with a horrible stench coming from within.
Harvest meats, ink.
I don't think it's human.
I don't want to see this part.
I actually don't want to though.
I'm okay with most stuff but I don't want to see this.
Uh...
Let chat play.
I know I have to.
Oh wait, I only just saved up bees.
I think I don't have to save again.
It's okay.
I don't have to go here yet?
Okay, we'll come back then.
Let's go.
Let's go to the Johnson.
Why is he always really upset with...
Or obsessed with the cat meat?
Steve how's the husband to be I'm having no memory I guess I'm all right all right holy you should be ecstatic considering what you're getting into if you haven't gotten into it already what does that mean speaking of which I heard Stephanie was grounded her daddy's worried about getting his meat so if I were him I'd more concerned about Stephanie getting some meat right and you are you always were a kid or Steve I'm mr.
Johnson remember glad you stopped by just got finished waxing the Tucker I could use a little relaxation but since Edna's not here i might as well talk to you sure uh oh but who's edna edna fitzpatrick is one of the snootiest women in town i declare there is an i declare that turned me away if i was interested that is oh sure just because she owns dna's she's got all these highfalutin ideas about independence and her with a little girl to raise that child needs a father and Edna well she needs a good hard penis what
makes you so sure she needs a penis you seeing Edna's getting it from someone else like maybe that damn sheriff Dwayne Dwayne he's sheriff every day from noon to one feeding his dad gum pie and i got a feeling he'd like edna for dessert oh sure it's the only diner in town but i'm sure he's got more of his mind than food i think you're projecting mr no not the sheriff dwayne dwayne No!
No!
Anybody but him!
I'll admit DNA's diner does good business.
Why?
What is the name DNA's diner?
That's weird.
Can money keep you warm at night?
Can you wrap your thighs around it?
Rigged bloody gases in its back with your painted hollered fingernails?
Edna?
Fuck.
So, how's Stephanie?
How does it feel getting out freaked?
I, like, bro is crashing out.
I was, oh my gosh, octopus.
I was thinking the same thing.
It was so like a, oh, hi, Steve.
Oh, hi, Bark.
is that speaking of stephanie i still haven't gotten an invitation to the wedding yet i don't have anything to do with that that's okay the chicken getting shot in the background what is happening you could use the back seat of my tucker for the for a pass to the voyage it's plenty big believe you and me did he just ask to come on the honeymoon and i wouldn't look in the back seat guarantee it though if you'd like to come up front and take the wheel a while i wouldn't say nay his eyes are so insane
painted harlot fingernails this guy's so this is so insane heck of an automobile isn't she the tucker damn shame i have to sit out here and watch over the time but if I didn't those stupid kids might scratch her up playing ball oh can I take a look at it don't see why not but don't touch her okay mighty particular about my Tucker I had the garage remodeled like a fortress so I could lock her up at night and get some sleep I'm sure she's safe enough inside a few months back someone broke into my house trying to get into the the garage.
I had to gripe like hell before the sheriff agreed to start the evening patrols and instigate the curfew.
Curfew?
I'm gonna steal his car.
Bye now.
Bye.
During the day, Mr. Johnson keeps watch over his precious 48 Tucker.
I can't go inside.
The garage.
Mr. Johnson erected an impenetrable fortress to protect his Tucker during the night.
Okay.
Wow, that guy was Where's the...
I want to go see Edna.
Oh, wait.
It's here, right?
Oh, there's a TV station.
I think I missed that.
Edna's diner.
I'm curious about here.
A 1955 Frag 100 with a real leather seat.
Oh, DNA is because the E is out.
I see.
Oh, Steve, what are you doing?
sneaking up on me like that god for a second i thought you were mr johnson not mr johnson please what would you like to order you know me sure and my name's edna fitzpatrick i'm not the one with amnesia then you believe me well you always were a kid or steve i guess i've changed i'm not kidding now steve faking amnesia won't help her face if you don't If you don't want to marry Stephanie,
then don't.
But don't play sick for heaven's sake.
I'd expect that from Karen, not an 18-year-old.
Karen is the kid down here.
You've met Karen, my 8-year-old.
Other than the diner, she's all I have.
Yeah, we're like a really tough 18.
They keep saying we're 18, but I'm like, How many times?
You always wear a kidder window.
There isn't a nicer girl in Harvest than Stephanie's Eve.
Yeah, 18 going on 30.
You should be grateful that she's promised you her hand.
I don't remember that happening, Edna.
Honestly, you men are so childish.
I don't know what it is about marriage that turns even the bravest man into a coward.
I was going to marry Karen's father.
when he just up and ran out on me one night.
Oh, my God.
I heard that he'd joined the lodge.
The lodge!
But if he did, I never saw him come out again.
Even Sheriff Dwayne wasn't able to find out what happened to him.
No.
Um, I'm really curious about Mr. Johnson.
Mr. Johnson has a liking for me.
Uh...
I call it a crush, but that's too innocent a word.
He's a bitter man with too much time on his hands.
He's never gotten over being rejected by him.
by the lodge and there's something unwholesome in the way unwholesome I'm always glad when the sheriff comes in every day at noon the lodge the lodge is the repository of all wisdom you should join the order of the harvest moon Steve and soon why for God's sake what is it about me apparently they're rejecting everybody ripens and waits not for the side there's only 50 people here in this town that he used the to rip his own stomach out than to stay his side when the wheat ripens.
The harvest moon wanes and then comes winter.
An empty belly, the body sun's belly, gurgling within or bloody on the ground.
What does it benefit a man if he gains his soul and loses the world?
You hunger.
Feed yourself before it's too late.
Oh.
Edna?
Steve.
What happened?
Were we talking about Boyle?
Or was it Karen?
You seem strange there for a minute.
I'm sorry.
I'm under a lot of stress.
Running this diner all alone.
Forgive me.
Oh.
Interesting.
Okay.
I'm still waiting on my order.
Postmaster Boyle.
Though I see them together a lot, Boyle and the sheriff never act very friendly towards each other.
I need the postmaster to give me the application.
Almost like there's some kind of bond between them besides friendship.
Though what it might be, I can't imagine.
Maybe Sheriff Dwayne resents the fact that he's never been able to get into the lodge.
Though that's not Boyle's fault.
He just hands out the applications.
He doesn't decide who gets admitted.
And the sheriff?
Sheriff Dwayne is such a dear man.
A dear man.
And I didn't just say that because he's my most regular customer.
Every single day, rain or shine, he comes in here at noon for lunch.
Sits in the same spot, too.
That's at least an hour every day when I can be sure Mr. Johnson won't show up.
Bellow yellow.
You know, it's funny.
Dwayne never comes in here with Deputy Rookie.
Yeah, he's a dear man.
I wouldn't be surprised if he had books.
You know, the owner of the TV station.
Sometimes he comes in with Postmaster Boy.
but somehow I don't think they're friends is nobody friends TV station mr.
McKnight owns the TV station WHAR he seems to get along with Sheriff Dwayne better than Boyle does okay better than just about anyone to tell the truth I don't see the connection between them but I'll bet you dollars to donuts that it's there anyhow I see you bye stop by anytime Steve thank you Edna mr.
kid what's your name Karen Sharon.
What are you doing?
Playing.
My mom is working, so I gotta stay out of her hair.
Wanna play?
Not now, maybe later.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Uh...
Oh, I'm trying to...
Oh, even from the ground you can hear the sonorous buzz of the neon.
I don't know if I said that right.
Okay, let's see if...
Um, the TV, okay, wait, I think the...
Probably we need to go... Oh, let's go to the mortuary.
This is where we're getting married?
Wait, it's actually quite nice!
Oh, no, that's the symbol.
The hideous symbol stands out like a...
AHH!
Or a spider.
I was thinking it looked...
Um...
Like, uh, what's it called?
like a oh my gosh like a Pokemon symbol I don't even see the squash spider Steve that's my last name for the record I don't own a TV station are you sure are you sure.
Sideways, see?
The cool symbol, the cool S.
A large translucent window.
Professionally kept landscape.
Let's go in.
It's quiet.
Schedule of this week's funerary events.
How many people are dying in this town?
It's population 51.
Soon to be 50.
Pair of comfortable looking sofas.
Hmm.
on today's episode young minto visits a town where nearly everyone she runs into is freakier than she is turns out you can be too freaky i'm not even that freaky you guys you know i do wear the freak phantom title with pride but i definitely know i'm not the freakiest phantom empty coat tree Let's go to the door on the left.
Oh, that...
The sound effects are...
It sounded like the sound effect from the Zubini's.
The heart, a disembodied organ which was never meant to pump formaldehyde.
Oops, he spilled.
Eww!
It sounds just like a symphony sound effect.
Very nasty looking sink.
On the counter sits a new tube of astroglu.
Temperature gauge.
Here I'll turn it down for everybody who gets bothered by this.
The needle lies on 33 degrees Fahrenheit.
Ooh, chilly.
The fans wearing blades barely stir the stench-laden air.
Hermito is tastefully freaky.
Thank you.
Mr. Moynihan.
Stephen.
Who are you?
Abraham Lincoln.
I am Daniel Moynihan.
Mortician and proprietor of the Wayward Hotel.
Wow.
Most people ask me why I don't remember their names.
Well, you always were a kidder, Steve.
Besides, as one who deals with the dead, I try not to involve myself in the affairs of the living.
Your loss of memories of no concern to me, true or false.
Ironic, considering my recent involvement in a charity event.
Sometimes sounds like someone's flushing a toilet.
My complaints were central to the scheduling of the upcoming harvest bake sale.
I'm gratified the order of the harvest moon got involved.
The proceeds will certainly help cover my losses.
Oh, what the bake sale.
This bake sale is a joint effort of the harvest PTA and the order of the harvest moon.
seeds will be used to set up a fund for transients in other words bonds and societal rejects without families who wander into harvest or uninvited then the order is setting up shelters for the homeless not shelters you see a great number of these hobos die while passing through don't ask me why it's what those people do use your common sense steven they're getting turned into the meat if they were involved in setting up the cannibalism why would i be involved and why would i be sustaining losses
losses it seems that like some elephants graveyard people of low station come to harvest to die they simply drop penniless and they all need burials god knows it feels like we're in life though the wayward hotel i do more than my fair share so why must i pay for the coffins like in between and the afterlife you know my losses to the dead this is angel beats but bad the bake sale yeah purgatory purgatory effort of the harvest pta and the order of the harvest moon the proceeds will be used to set up a fund for transience in other words angel beats that's what i said rejects without families who wander into harvest uninvited then the order is setting up shelters for the homeless not shelters graves oh wait he already said that part order of the harvest moon as always the order of the harvest moon has taken the lead in addressing our societal ills through their sponsorship of the blood drive and the bake sale the lodge ensures that all our needs are met needs Such as...
Yeah, such as...
Pardon me, there are corpses to prepare.
Oh, excuse me?
And my losses have been substantial of late.
If you're sincerely interested in the order, however, you should stop by the lodge and speak with the sergeant at odds.
I keep trying!
Why should I be interested, Mr. Moynihan?
Of all the spots in Harvest, the lodge is the most prominent, literally and figuratively.
They would explain also why, like...
It is the ambition of everyone here to join.
And join you must to attain wisdom.
Why Edna's...
If I knew I'd be a member.
Went in and never came back.
I have the feeling you have what it takes to join the order, Stephen.
If this is like a purgatory.
Whether or not you live up to your potential is up to you.
Did I talk about the bake sale?
Uh, we'll just leave.
It's fine.
Oh, whoops.
I don't know what he said, my bad.
Examine the corpse.
The messy remains of some poor soul.
Okay, boy?
Whoa.
The light from the candelabra gleams unwholesomely pink.
Why is everything pink?
This game is mocking me.
Like the eyes of a horde of rats balancing on thin wires.
The pews.
Rows and rows of empty wooden pews, caked with the dust of indifference.
Oh!
A lectern.
A small lectern for a priest.
I haven't saved in a bit.
Let's save.
Pink.
Okay.
Examine the window.
A hauntingly beautiful stained glass window in which a man holds a scythe in one hand and some ethereal power in the other.
A saint kneels before a shepherd.
Jubilently terrified.
image just flipped okay the brass candelabra holds several strange smelling candles wait an empty vessel of the dead oh I was gonna say is there something in the casket and the imprint of a hand buttocks and sliding heels are scraped into the thick dust of the pew
head and butt and sliding heels you say
How for what reason would they be sliding for?
Why is the head...
Pretty normal stuff, yeah?
Did someone say but?
Let's go to the cemetery.
This place...
Whoa!
Here lies boxcar Willy.
The air here reeks of fresh soil and manure.
Two years in harvest was too long.
Fear not in death.
Monty Jakes.
The scripture on the headstone has faded beyond legibility.
November 27th, 1948.
Another unknown visitor.
Stop, stop, stop.
It's another resting place amongst the graves.
Okay.
We're walking.
Whoa.
The marble doors have been sealed shut.
There's a big old crypt!
We can blow it up!
Just like in the druids.
All we gotta do is throw something at it.
The Potsdam family crypt.
Wait, what?
What?
Why do they have such a crazy crypt?
Yeah, the salt!
The salt!
We just gotta throw the salt and it'll explode.
I've learned!
So far, we've just kind of been wandering around.
We haven't done, like, anything with the stuff that I have, you know?
Hmm.
Can I go to the cemetery on this side?
Is it the same?
Let's see.
Boxcar Willy?
Wait.
Boxcar Willy.
Okay, never mind.
What is this place?
A hotel!
Wayward...
In?
Is that what I said?
There is vacancy.
What the?
How did you get in here?
The door is locked.
Reflections make the lobby seem more spacious than it actually is.
Young man, we really have nothing to say to each other.
I have the feeling your image shall soon adorn my slab.
And I'd rather not know the face of the meat I'm slicing.
Oh, sir, this is a hotel.
Hotel.
As owner of the only hotel in town, I do my best to accommodate any hobo who straggles into town, vacancy is permitted.
Uh...
Were the guys who dropped dead staying at your hotel?
I really don't recall.
We get so many low-life dregs passing through here I can't remember every little death that occurs.
Oh my god!
Are there that many?
As I said, Slice open on a mortician's slab, every corpse looks the same.
For him.
And juicy.
But surely you'd remember if these deaths were an unusual occurrence.
You sound like you're launching some sort of investigation, Stephen.
Stephen.
That would be most unwise.
Oh, so he is Stephen.
Okay, bye.
I'd say it's been a pleasure, but I find the company of the living so wearisome.
Radio.
The somewhat ponderous console radio evokes an earlier era.
I can't really do anything in here, I suppose.
Wait, the ledger?
A ledger of names, the last being Jonathan A.
Reinkliff.
Checked in Monday.
Okay, bye!
See ya!
Alright, on to the next location.
The fire!
Oh no!
Wait, we cannot become a fireman.
Newspaper building and police station.
Let's see if the sheriff is in town.
Who's that?
The cop ignores you.
Too busy writing a bug report.
okay this is him it is sheriff Dwayne hello Steve let me introduce myself I'm sheriff Dwayne Dwayne and this here is Loomis pleasure I reckon we haven't met before of course we have but I heard about your alleged amnesia and figured I'd play along I sure hope this is just a prank and not the start of some insanity please keep your nose clean or you'll wind up in jail and that's no place to hold a wedding i'd be gonna go to jail just because i have amnesia it's not my fault dwayne dwayne why do you want to break your poor mama's heart with all this amnesia bunk i'm telling you the truth why won't anyone believe me is it because i'm a kidder you've always been a kidder steve yeah So everybody keeps telling me.
Boy, you need to stop all this funning and get serious.
You've got a wedding coming up soon.
Heck, you should be thinking about your career and about joining the launch.
This is the perfect reason not about the boy who cried wolf.
And if you start, if you are the boy who cried wolf, everybody will start calling you a kidder.
Amnesia or no, you can't have forgotten you're about to marry the prettiest little thing at Harvest.
I think you and Stephanie are perfect for each other.
I just hope her father's disappointment doesn't spoil it.
Wait, wait, all he wants is me.
Disappointment?
Mr. Potsdam wants to hold a wedding in the lodge, but he'll never get in.
It's so weird.
Like all the rest, he's always hanging around the post office the first day of the month.
Waiting for Boyle to bring out that much lodge.
I don't know if I would recommend.
There's always a long line.
Never enough applications to go around.
an application chances are you're right out of luck viewer call to the order and even less accepted allison wonderland meets midsummer they've turned him down so many times unless he does something radical he'll never get in uh crime crime wise nothing much has happened in harvest since the newspaper fire this paper fire oh sure every week or so we get the odd transient dropping you But other than that,
it gets pretty slow around here.
Kiwawa's point-and-click adventure arc incoming?
Please!
Kiwawa, I think this game gets kind of...
Sure.
You remember?
The Sentinel building burned down about six months ago.
That's what I'm telling you, Sheriff.
I don't remember anything.
Why won't you believe I have amnesia?
Well, you've always been a...
kidder steve anyway the fireman said the fire was caused by arson i never caught the perp though but we found the gas can that was used yes sir re bob it's in the evidence room he's talks that's classified darn it talk so slow how many times you're gonna have to tell me to keep my mouth shut i wonder sorry boss you've got the gas can in the evidence room did you dust it for prince
you've been watching too much tv steve heck just a box you can make out all those curvy lines anyhow no it's sitting in there gathering dust oh okay is the day we found it just in case i ever need a spare gas can that case is closed it's not closed you never you never you never solved it what's lumus without him I'd have a hard time keeping the peace or at least taking a lunch break mainly Loomis answers the phone and babysits the office while I'm out though sometimes he likes to go in the back and stain the jail mattress isn't that right Loomis oh now sheriff what you gotta go and say that for Loomis has more than his share of problems I wouldn't invite him to the I wouldn't invite him.
Or if you do, make sure he doesn't catch the garter.
That could be embarrassing.
Oh, I wouldn't do nothing, Dwayne.
But I sure would like a little garter than being around Stephanie's thigh.
Oh, well, that'd be right, special.
I think we need to have, I think we need to make, stop Loomis from speaking.
Bye.
anytime, Steve.
Thank you.
The door is locked.
Wait, is this the evidence room?
The door is locked?
That's the evidence room.
Ah!
Where we store items lifted from crime scenes.
Yes, yes.
It's kept locked at all times.
Okay, we gotta get Mr. Dwayne out.
Make people jump through hoops.
And then we'll probably Loomis won't care if we go into the evidence room.
I think that guy won't care at all.
Okay, so what's so wrong with fire, man?
I do wonder.
Please excuse the mess.
They've done wonders with the upstairs bedroom.
But this garage defies color coordination.
A fire truck with a lovely shade of pink.
Please excuse the mess.
Oh!
the dog up saliva is foaming from his barking chops what's happening here don't bother me i'm sketching oh look what you made me do oh i'm so sorry sparky welcome to the house of flame as we like to call it oh cut it out spots honestly one thing gets barking a good piece of meat is the only way to shut him up there you go spot there you go oh Very important Very important to have The cutscene of The dog licking his lips I'm fire marshal Sparky Head of your fire department Sparky My friend is a fireman I guess this is what he actually does all day When you're waiting for fires What else are you supposed to do?
I don't think He's not nude He's definitely have Okay Oh no, the alien music is back.
Why are you sketching nude men in the fire department?
Please.
It's not the subject, it's the process.
Don't be such a party group.
We're talking about art.
I can't hear you over.
Besides, we haven't had a fire and harvest since the newspaper building burned down.
Though I'll admit that the Wasp Woman's place is one big accident waiting to happen.
This is what some of you guys' fan art of me looks like, you know?
What is happening?
What's going on?
What's that supposed to mean?
That's just my booty.
They were like, get the dog in as many shots as possible.
Everybody just wants to see the dog.
Wasp woman.
Wait, let's go in order.
Art enriches the community, Steve.
No less than a pulsing fire hose or a fireman beating down a blazing door.
So what if we're drawing a nudes man?
The Lisp's are atrocious.
The only ever draws a nude man or the same nude man over and over in all sorts of provocative positions.
Provocative?
Procrast, not subject.
Don't be so ghosty, it's beneath you.
Oh, my bad.
oh newspaper fire a dreadful affair you wouldn't think that a brick and steel building with a sprinkler system could go up that quickly maybe you were too busy trying to put it out was it arson had to have been actually yeah oh please Dwayne was glad enough to see the thing go up and so was night if you could get into that safe and his wall forget it look Steve as far as I know the fire was an accident let's just leave it at that oh now don't you go moving
oh he I don't think he did who
just crashed oh my god the wasp woman Some people think all we do is sit around, sketching fetching examples of manhood for our own amusement.
Nothing could be farther from the truth.
Why, just the other day we sighted Ted threw a crumb for firecoat violations.
All the dried-out paper wasp nests clustered around our wooden house.
Why, it's a Kenlog just waiting for the right faggot.
Believe me, none of us wants to see another fiasco like the Sentinel fire.
but what's her deal why does she like the wasps okay we asked about hey bye oh male model I could talk to him I don't converse on the job Steve
oh I didn't get to ask about spots hold on can't talk now Steve I'm inspired no no spots the dog is that the dog right spots wait spot the pedantic watchdog but like the rest of us he has one awful vice none of us can resist why do they keep showing me the booty oh okay that's uh goodbye i'm examining the dog did i talk to this guy stop it you're messing me up oh yeah i forgot i did this is such a nice firehouse A painting?
Phallic-like structures.
Standing all in a row.
The lights are too high up to reach.
Okay.
I don't understand the alien.
What's happening?
Okay, the newspaper building.
Is it still like...
I was going to say, is it still like...
Wow, it really burnt down.
What's left of the newspaper building after...
an extreme fire.
The alien's here too.
At least the plumbing held up.
The shovel.
Shovel is sticking out of the building's ashes.
Mysterious.
Hmm.
Three fire hydrants and the building still burned down?
Miss.
Can I grab it?
Oh, I can!
What's left of the newspaper building after an extreme fire?
Oh, there it is.
Bake.
A supplier for the harvest bake sale.
A postal worker's button, and it looks like it was ripped from the cloth.
Now we're getting somewhere.
Nice, nice, nice.
Sometimes because I can examine.
something but then afterwards i have to like it then afterwards says operate sometimes i forget like i thought about grabbing the shovel but i didn't realize if i could or not okay we went to the diner already so let's go to the tv but okay hold on let's save wait i can't save yet we'll go to the tv station and save what is going on here okay save
six but they're popping off hello too busy drinking and smoking what's going on oh they're filming oh it's like a oh okay hello stay tuned buckaroos there's more to come on range riders cowboy roundup Oh.
So don't go away.
And what's your name, Hombre?
Hombre?
Steve's a swell name.
My dog's name is Steve.
How'd they write that right?
Would you like my autograph, Steve?
What?
Uh...
Yeah.
Here you go then.
Hombre.
TV violence.
Violence?
What about it?
I love all the blood and gore on you.
This is the show that our alleged little brother was watching.
Children, watch your show.
Don't you think this violence is bad for them?
I love all the blood it got.
What red-blooded American doesn't?
Nothing like an exploding head to get the blood pumping.
Literally that is.
Even so, do you think society pays a heavy price for the violence in the media?
Of course they pay a heavy price.
Just look at the net profits.
They'll line up around the block to see a good slaughter.
Now, excuse me, we're going back on the air.
Wait, is someone going to actually die?
You think?
A corny Western backdrop.
Complete with the cardboard teepee.
Aw, no one is operating the cameras.
Pew!
Wait, can we watch?
Either the show isn't compelling or no one wanted to be taken out by friendly fire.
I think we can go this way.
Oh!
Mr. McKnight!
Very poor reception.
Strange since the broadcast originates from here.
Hello!
Hey, Sport.
This is a private office.
Yeah, I know.
Mr. McKnight.
I like how you can still hear the alien music.
They really just snuck it in there.
I've lost my memory.
That's news.
War.
the hell it is you always were a kidder steve how does everybody any real news to tell me actually i was just wanting to know more about the tv i can't hear you over the everything w-h-a-r is the only television station in harvest since the old sentinel went under what with the newspaper building burning down and all war has changed nobody competes with us yeah that's a strange thing to say kidder been well and always steve you've what an odd coincidence hey now sport that's an irresponsible allegation I had nothing to do with that fire just because WHAR may have benefited from it and I danced on the ashes a little doesn't mean I torched a little you can ask Sheriff Dwayne you have any doubts you seem awfully touchy on the subject sport I'm touchy when people try to muscle their way into my business I'd appreciate it if you leave my office.
And don't come back.
Uh-huh.
Cubicles.
An assortment of empty cubicles.
Either McKnight loves to recall his salad days as an insurance salesman.
Or he can't keep his employees happy.
A picture of a gorgeous model signed with Kiss My Pineapple.
What?
I kind of want some fruit.
Wait.
So people don't die here?
Silver Tucker.
Oh, Tucker.
Uh, okay.
The Memorial School.
I think I...
Wait, did I save?
Oh, yeah, I did.
Because I did button.
That's right.
We're going back to school.
Bake sale.
Oh, yeah.
Principal Harold.
Steve, good of you to drop by, big guy.
Big guy.
I haven't seen you since graduation.
a lot of changes i hear you could say that we've only seen one good good that's a nice part of my job turning fine young men and women out into the world and then watching them prosper of course i was able to reach more people at the old sentinel god bless her but then again i never got to see the results of my work up close before who are you who are you you know very well i'm mr herald the principle of gain memorial Steve I've heard about this amnesia nonsense I had hopes you'd be in the lodge by now fine young fellow like yourself but now I think maybe you need a little more quality time
what did he mean by that quality time what did he mean by that I'm scared this game scares me this game It was real horror.
Boy, I sure missed the old newspaper.
The sheriff never did investigate that fire properly.
Call it a newspaper man's instinct.
Though I can't imagine why Sheriff Dwayne would cover up anything.
I mean, the only ones who stood to profit from the newspaper going out of business was the owner of the TV station.
And Mr. Magnite had an airtight alibi.
Didn't they say Mr. Magnite and the post office guy?
I never would have wound up as principal of...
Like, you gotta get out of here, me too!
The creepy children in the background.
Keen Memorial.
Sounds like a cemetery or a hospital, not a school.
This institution was named for a great man.
Whose first name, excuse me.
He epitomized the great potential within us all, big guy.
Big guy.
I hear there's an honorary plaque commemorating him.
Within the lodge.
So we gotta get...
The lodge.
It's not Ed, is it?
That would be insane.
Stop calling me Big Guy.
The greatest gift I can bestow upon you as your former principal is a word of advice.
Join the order of the Harvest Moon at any cost.
Big Guy.
Within the lodge lies your future and without...
dust dust yeah um big guy why do you keep calling me big guy a sign of respect lad as principal my station is higher than yours now but you never know what the future holds so you should always hedge your bets oh wait that's kind of cute to your inferior oh wait you never know who will come to power or who even now wheels it behind the scenes for all i know you might already be a member yeah we are a little bit wide it's not my fault i'd be all that much better off having shown you respect and spent some quality time with you i keep saying it like that
you were oh you always were a big guy you kidder you surprised that even the big the guy has been awarded the title big guy wait but i kind of i kind of like it you get you call everyone a big guy because you're just like you know in the future you could be the big guy and i'm i'm respecting you that you i believe that you have big things coming and so you call him a big guy it's kind of cute wait that's kind of cute try calling us that hey big guy
i don't like it never mind i i I erased my opinion.
What's the quality time?
What do you mean, quality time?
Some, like Miss Whaley, favor stern discipline.
Corporal punishment as a means of socialization.
Socialization.
I temper discipline with love.
Quality time can be such a warm, sharing experience.
After just a few sessions, You'd stop this amnesia nonsense and become a productive member of society and a fit candidate for the lodge.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Drop in again soon.
Adult education is a wonderful thing, as is adult quality time.
Oh my god, the way he says it.
Nobody in this town is normal.
Where did they find the voice actors for this game?
It's insane.
Oh, wait, sorry.
I was just...
The door is locked.
The lockers are riddled with inexplicable stains and dents.
But there was something here.
Let's go there.
Come on.
Wait, there are children here.
Oh, my gosh.
Miss Whaley.
A rough sketch of the lodge.
The children look stunning.
and zombified yeah I would be stunned and zombified too if I lived in this hell scape of a town the music even the paper cutouts look stunned and zombified I can't get over how he keeps reading it as koala tea time a
projector engineered to sound good when played underwater?
Mint, we might need an actual grown-up.
Yeah, I know.
This place is scary.
My goodness, class, this is Stevens.
He used to be a student here at Geen Memorial.
Say hello, class.
They're reticent.
The educator's greatest problem today is the apathy of the students.
I can't hear you over the music.
What's wrong with their heads?
I can tell you in one word, Stevens.
Discipline.
Thank goodness you weren't a sulky bear.
smiley bear then you remember me not as such so many pupils Steven they come and they go but I can always spot those who were nice boys you can tell from the forehead the lows right class thank you so much I'm glad you stopped by Steven would you care to say a few words to the class about civic responsibility not really I was just passing through oh but you must Steven a positive role model might be just the thing to inspire these little monsters.
Steven, have you any questions for me?
Or shall I continue with class?
Uh, sure.
Sure.
Yeah, I have some questions.
Ask away then.
Yes, pause music?
Wait, actually, I want to say...
Stop by anytime, Steven.
Also, actually, this music is...
Is this the same classroom?
Okay, yeah.
Save.
Beautiful silence, I know.
We'll come, we'll come back.
Where were you?
Wow, what a school.
We gotta find a way into the lodge.
Now I still don't want to go to the meat plant because...
I don't want to go.
But the missile base, we went and then I didn't talk to anybody.
Or I talked to this guy and then I left.
Who goes there?
It's just me.
Steve.
Just me.
Did the llamas send you?
Lamas?
Uh, of course they did.
I knew it.
They won't leave me alone.
Them in the Kukaburos.
Nine!
Okay,
the llamas are not good.
Wait, I think we just...
I think we...
just um oops
ah load game good thing we just saved
that oh that did quite escalate um quite quickly i might have beat the game just now i need an adult i am an adult okay how do i get out of here Nope, not that way.
Uh, where's the...
It's like not letting me exit.
Wait.
Oh, here it is.
Oh my gosh, it's pixel perfect.
Okay, let's go back.
Why does this place exist?
Who goes there?
It's just me.
Steve!
What do you want?
Did the llamas send you?
No, the llamas fear me.
That's good.
Someone has to keep them in check.
Check.
I'm glad you stopped by again.
I want you to infiltrate those firemen, mister.
Oh, okay.
There's a lot of art going on over there.
I want to make sure they haven't turned into Kami bastards.
Is that what the art is?
And don't come back unless you've got information for me.
Oh.
Bye.
Remember duck and cover?
Remember the alamo.
These are some, like, hefty...
This base is well stocked with missiles.
like these are some really big missiles i think you would blow a hole to the other side of the earth
we don't like that sissy art stuff what's this looks like mr pastorelli forgot to point out the paper for jimmy or put out the paper oh my gosh jimmy is is breaking holes into people's houses i prefer vtubers that don't Don't start nuclear war.
I'm not!
No!
It's not me!
Yeah, we're in the 50s.
Somewhere, during this time, somewhere Peace Walker is happening.
Sorry, son.
No time to talk.
Neither rain nor sleep nor snow nor hell shall keep the mail from its appointed rounds.
I thought he was gonna rhyme.
Um, I have your button, mister.
What's that you say?
Oh, yes, my button.
It's been missing for months now.
I keep meaning to get another, but, well, the button's very distinctive.
I'd have to file an S-411 with Washington to get another, and I just don't need the extra paperwork.
Sure wish I could find it.
Next time you post, don't forget the zip code!
My button!
Where did you find it?
Funny thing, that.
Yeah.
I found it in the ashes.
At the newspaper building.
Yeah.
What are you implying?
That I had something to do with setting the fire?
His face is so scrunched up.
Why a hundred people must have visited that site since the fire?
But none of them had buttons like this.
You just try showing that button to Sheriff Dwayne, son.
He'll laugh you right out of his office.
Okay.
Wait, maybe I could try again.
my button why I lost funny thing what do you let's see you we both know you set that fire and what if I did I guess I'd be pretty grateful to anyone who could help get me off the hook how you seem like a capable lad hypothetically let's say there was a gas can sitting in the evidence room at the sheriff's office a gas can which might have some incriminating prints on it uh-huh Someone might be very grateful for the return of that gas can.
Say, grateful enough to provide whoever returned it with a lodge application.
Oh, and Steve, you'll keep this to yourself.
Oh, ooh.
The boss's other son, Revolver Ocelot's brother, Kidder Steve.
Look at his idle animation.
Okay, let's leave.
Let's leave.
I don't think it was a threat.
I think it was a bit of a trade, rather.
You know?
They're like, come...
They're like, get that evidence.
Wait.
We know that...
What's his name?
It's...
At noon here at the diner.
He's there!
Tori, thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you!
hello there steve here for lunch no just here looking around though i'm not entirely sure where here is oh i forgot the zip codes weren't induced until the 60s well boy this is dna's diner isn't that right don't listen to sheriff dwayne this is edna's diner but ever since the e burned out on the sign they've been giving me a hard time now don't be like that didn't i it's a great place to eat which is good jacob thank you for the gift since it's the only place eating harvest oh okay bye yeah i mean it is the only place stop on by anytime steve all right we gotta get to the we gotta get to the police station stat pronto and thank you no thank you gert thank you thank you all so much for the gifted thank you thank you thank you oh my goodness police station this game is kind of wackadoo so uh
Loomis Anything I can help you with Loomis That coffee sure smells good Help yourself Speaking of which You're real lucky to be marrying Stephanie She don't look like a good woman I just hope she don't turn out like Mrs. Loomis Her mercy forbid Mrs. Phelps Good women can be awful hard on a man's needs,
don't you know?
What?
Stephanie.
Oh, well gosh darn, she's pretty.
Kind of like a gal I've seen on some of them French postcards.
Can I have the key?
Can I knock this guy out, actually?
Used to be.
take them things go back into jail if nobody was there and kind of look them over one hand and fold some towels that was before mrs lomas what happened to mrs lomas you were married oh gosh i wish i had some of them girly pictures but mrs lomas won't let me keep oh you're still married I still remember the time she caught me holding some of them pictures up with one hand.
Stop saying that.
I just took the broom to me.
I hound like a hound dog.
The broom going up and down.
Flashing straw and blood, blood and straw.
Blood?
Brute, I was crying so bad and it was so hard I had to crawl under the porch neck and...
With all the black winter spiders and I got...
bet something fierce little fangs are digging into my bear behind all over oh no i ask you is that any way to treat a man and mrs felts and the sheriff don't make it no easier top voice acting i know my goodness i'm sheriff dwayne yes sheriff dwayne let's get let's stop talking about women let me get around the little lady by letting me keep some of them picture books here even if mrs helps is let me buy one but see he won't let me keep none here neither he don't like me getting the jail mattress oh this is all you could talk about mr.
lupus I don't want to ask about the mattress I don't think this guy thinks about literally anything else oh my gosh imagine imagine if he if he were alive sometimes a man can be good with a gun or a knife but even so one-handed and all he can get a little off when his aim make no shame in it that's why the good lord made evaporation and such but the sheriff he don't like it and don't pay no mind to a man's needs no more than mrs loomis bless her uh bye in a time kiddo don't call me that pot hisses at you from its perch can i take it i need to get in there unsolved arson right on thank you so much for the vibe get dead it's labeled unsolved arson and it's full okay uh a map of harvest wait how do we get in there though i thought Wait,
wait!
I know!
I know what we need to do!
He's been talking about this the whole time!
We need to give him the magazine!
No, I spent a whole quarter for this magazine.
That'll get him away!
He'll go to the mattress!
Oh.
By George.
Oh, by Jiminy.
Here's the real thing.
Oh, Jiminy.
Can I have it?
Sure.
Oh, thank you, Steve.
That's the real deal.
Excuse me, get home.
I gotta go check the jail for clean tiles.
Hey, get out of here.
He walks...
So fast, thank goodness.
Okay, examine now, let's see.
Examine the drawer, drawer is unlocked, open it up, grab the keys, key to the evidence room, yippee, what's the note, a barely legible note, checkbook, a sheriff's way's checkbook, let me in, okay cool, yay, into the evidence, oh, uh, evidence room, to the evidence room,
yay!
I can pick those up too, can I?
What is going on in here?
Oh!
Hello, Steve.
Where's Loomis?
Uh-oh.
Oh, that's good.
Loomis, stab you!
Wait, no!
No!
Uh, no!
Setting up the mattress again!
Wait, did I just ruin my...
Okay, good.
Pick it up.
Oh, there we go.
Pick up the note.
Oh, thank you so much.
I totally missed that.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Right click to view the checkbook.
Wait, there could be some incriminating things in here.
Deposit boil.
Deposit war.
Does that say $15,000?
Sounds like someone got paid off.
Tulips ammunition.
Ah!
It's a lot of dollars.
Sheriff, if you think I'm going to keep paging, this forever you are crazy there are limits boil oh paying this forever who was boil again
this one looks like one of luma's late relatives this prop helps the sheriff meet his parking tickets quota there are 50 people 50 50 five zero 50 people that live in this town and you're You have quotas?
One of the developers had to have to experience something like that in their life.
Seems too specific by getting slapped with a rolled up paper.
I don't know.
Not surprisingly, Loomis has tainted this evidence.
From the smell of it, you wouldn't want to open this refrigerator.
Real old-fashioned dartboard riddled with holes and crimson smears.
What's the Santa hat?
A vital clue in the mysterious, jolly fat man murder spree.
read lawn dart this makes sense they're illegal what's a lawn dart a pair of bloody sneakers he did not like green eggs and ham so they killed him what the hell an insta shot camera just point and click oh it's a checky camera this bathroom this bathroom kit is missing its razor
saw normal cap too small to fit a normal sized head oh the gas can okay oh no put it in my inventory dummy a Volkswagen engine sits rusted up to the core oh that's a plane I thought it was a gun a well-built 148th scale B 17 model the beer can is empty except for tar sediment pair of binoculars without lenses.
Cabinets are empty.
A padlock.
Slightly tarnished finish.
Toast!
That most improbable of all murder weapons.
Toast.
Lawn darts were a toy game you could buy back in the day.
You threw them up in the air and they had a metal spike that landed in the lawn.
Ban because they're obviously dangerous.
Oh!
What?
That's kind of insane.
Clearly an impertinent little vine...
What is...
I clicked on a bottle.
Big nose and woody finish.
Hmm?
Okay.
We got it.
We can go.
Alright.
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Cancel.
Not load.
Save.
Grab the sneakers.
Oh.
I forgot.
Where does that kid live?
But they're bloody.
Well, that didn't work.
Can I pick up anything else?
Oh, I can pick up the camera.
I'm just stealing all this evidence.
Yeah, it's mine.
Yoink.
Okay, now we can leave.
All right.
Save as
larceny.
Actually, it has to be like a really big theft to be larceny.
We'll just say petty theft.
Hours now.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, Phil, thanks for the toast.
I wonder what we use the camera for?
We've been to the barbershop, we've been to the post office.
Did we go to the general store?
I don't think we'd... Oh, yes I did!
That's where I got the magazine.
Just kidding.
Yes, yes, yes.
I missed a person at my house?
I did?
Oh, you're thinking grand larceny.
Larceny just means dealing with no intent to return.
Oh, I learned.
But where is Jimmy?
This is to my room, right?
Yeah.
Oh, my room.
My room.
These are the cookies.
Jimmy will appear next morning.
So we gotta...
It does...
If I click on me, it says...
Monday.
Okay.
Let's just do what we can for now here.
Uh...
Alright, I got the goods.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
After all this time...
Where's my application, Boyle?
Here, take it.
With my thanks.
You know, this morning as I was making my rounds, I noticed an awful lot of television aerials on the roofs.
Seems like more and more each day.
You've got me this can just in time, youngster.
I may have need of it again.
What do you mean?
Wait, well, yeah, what do you mean?
There's another reason why Sheriff Dwayne didn't investigate the Sentinel fire.
If you'd like to get something else on the blackmailing bastard, check around the television station.
Why are you still can?
Oh, I think...
I think Postmaster Boyle has a bit of an arsonist streak.
I think...
I think now that he's done it once, he can't stop himself again.
To the TV station!
Arsonist.
Uh...
If I go in here, and I talk to the big, big man, this guy, about this...
The checkbook, let's see what he says.
Oh, now sport.
This is really interesting Boyle's done something wrong.
Otherwise the sheriff wouldn't be blackmailing him But what God I'd love to nail him to the wall.
Yeah, and don't forget about the sheriff Dwayne is a blackmailer after all.
Wait, no.
Oh Yeah Sorry, I decided not to run with this story that kind of fire man, but this is all the evidence you need for your newscast Evidence of a blackmail situation canceled checks.
Wait, but also what about the the payment the war payment no can do matter of fact i think i may have to shoot the share of a private little news i haven't played it i'll look into it thank you i know i know it may cause you some problems but hey let's do lunch okay my treat what what wait hold on let's talk to it i hate this i hate this room don't hurry back i hate this room don't hurry back oh it's so loud
A fairly primitive form of mind control?
The apply sign?
Okay.
What else am I supposed to examine here?
I don't think any other people will talk to me.
Hmm.
Let's go to the diner.
Oh yeah, let's- oh that's right, we gotta apply for the lodge.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello.
Um, I have my...
What is this?
Note.
Wait, no, where's my lodge?
Oh, wait, I have a lodge application.
Have you obtained an application from the postmaster?
If you would find knowledge, you must seek it from the first realization of the wanting.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Did I miss it?
Ah!
Here it is.
Oh, I wish I could read it.
Oh, dang.
I thought I would be able to know the questions.
Hello!
What is...
I did get an autograph from this guy.
Someone's gonna want this autograph.
I know it.
Hello.
I have an application.
here i've told you what you must do until you've proven yourself i have nothing more to say wait what do you mean my application do i need to like fill it out do i actually need to fill it out look at his auto oh whoops it says howdy steve
What am I supposed to look at it?
Wait!
Is this the same handwriting as the note?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It might be.
The same writing as the note.
This one.
Maybe?
Let's check.
Let's wait.
Show him.
um hello boy sheriff dwayne sure isn't a postmaster boil for a lot offhand i'd say it looks like blackmail something fierce wonder what boil could have done and the sheriff a blackmailer my goodness hold on a sec we're back with the news flash buckaroos we've just gotten information from steve wait i'm doing this on tv stay tuned for further developments as as soon as Steve can come up with them.
Wait, oh.
Is that not your handwriting?
Can't talk now, Buckaroo.
We're on in just a sec.
Oh, okay.
Happy trails, Buckaroo.
Did I give him the...
I accidentally solved it, by the way.
Wait, what do you mean?
It says boiled.
What does it?
The name is on the note.
Hold on.
The music is driving me crazy too.
I'm confused of who I've talked to.
And everything.
Boy, Sheriff Dwayne sure is...
Okay.
That's the same thing.
Yeah, sorry, I can't read.
So true.
Like how you can see the green screen outline of everybody.
What?
How do I fill this out?
Where do I...
I don't have a pen.
Wait, I do!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Hold on, let's go back to my house.
Yeah, I have a pen!
I say as I say I don't have a pen?
That's a ticket.
Let's see what he wrote.
How much do you...
Something something.
Three times a day.
Okay.
First name, Steve.
Middle, oh, maybe middle name, last name.
Nobody will tell me.
Maybe that's street something.
City harvest.
How often do you eat meat?
Do you have any physical disabilities that prove you from something, something?
No.
Do you something, something, something?
Do you enjoy...
People watching?
Yes?
Huh?
And then...
I don't even know what it is.
I...
Maybe they'll...
They say it to us later.
Hello!
Hello, sir!
Here is my application for the lodge.
I see you've managed to acquire an application yes that demonstrates resourcefulness he's all he's smiling for prospective members you need a rest report back here for your next assignment oh
I don't want to see please ah the Ah!
Ah!
What do you people want from me?
Welcome to our horror.
I won.
Oh, cheeseburger!
Oh, ow!
What is...
Good morning!
We're in the same shirt as yesterday.
18, by the way.
Yeah, this guy.
I love our 30-year-old teenager.
Yeah, maybe the kid, actually.
Let's see if he wants the autograph.
Big whoopsie.
Okay, Hank.
whatever
big whip Steve hi mom hello dear how are you today bye bye oh something about Jimmy oh okay big whip Steve what do you want Steve Hank is a 1950s iPad kid still sick huh that's right I think I got the flu I think I got the flint.
Maybe you'd feel better if you stopped watching television and went to bed.
Maybe you'd be quiet with a stigma in your heart.
What?
Just leave me alone, Steve.
Believe me, you got your own problems.
Oh my god!
Good.
Find them.
My brother hates me.
Hello, Jimmy James.
Hey, did you ever find any sneakers?
Yes, I did.
Whoa, that's great.
Maybe we could try.
What could you give me?
You know this Waley and Principal Harold down at the school?
Unfortunately.
Well, I found out there messing around with each other in the broom closet.
What?
I can tell you when they meet and trade you some keys that'll let you catch some red-handed.
What do you say?
Oh, sure.
Take the...
Well, here's the keys to the broom closet at Gain Memorial.
That's where they meet every day.
As soon as everyone has gone home.
Sometimes I hide in there beforehand.
Daddy-o, I see some stuff that's real nasty.
Take it from me.
You made a good swap.
See you later, alligator.
Jimmy James!
You're hiding in the broom closet!
Jimmy James, where?
What would your parents think?
Wait, also, don't I have a newspaper?
Oh yeah, let's give this to him too.
Hey, Steve, you've been doing a swell job putting the paper out in the morning.
You just keep doing that and we won't have any problems.
That's not much to ask, is it?
I'm scared of Jimmy James.
What do you, why does he talk like a mafia boss?
Just keep doing that and we won't have any problems, right?
Yeah, let's punch him.
Yeah.
I've
been scared of Jimmy James!
I don't think I...
Oh, dang it.
I don't think I saved before the whole cutscene.
I didn't think it would do anything.
Oh, oops.
Pen, pen, pen.
That's a ticket.
Well, okay, wait.
There was one thing I think I wanted to do before I...
Handed in.
Maybe it was, I was going to try the autograph photo, but it didn't work.
So that's fine.
I just realized this is a very, very big inventory, isn't it?
Riposo.
Jimmy James is kind of insane.
Okay, we can just skip all this.
So sorry, everybody.
I'll save.
I say you've managed to...
Your sister is in a crib.
Yeah, yeah, I've interacted with it before.
Not it, sorry, the baby.
I've interacted with the sister before.
I'll try again, though.
Okay, let's save.
That's why you should not punch kids.
Scared of Jimmy James.
Jimmy James.
I didn't mean to say it, I'm sorry!
Oh, a newborn baby.
Yeah, see?
I interacted with her before.
Ew, it smells like dirty diapers.
Why in the kitchen?
Let's talk to Hank.
We'll ask this one.
Is Dad feeling any better?
I hear him at night, thrashing and moaning.
I crawl out my window.
I'm seeing Mom's shadow on his shade.
Pot holders on her hands.
Reaching for him.
How can she do the stitches on him wearing those?
Or didn't she slip?
Don't be silly.
I need to ask the mom about the baby.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, that's why he's not getting better.
Don't yell at me.
Good.
Finally.
Bye.
Okay, I'll ask the mom about the baby.
Hello, dear.
How are you today?
That's a baby.
I'll say baby.
Baby.
Stop speaking nonsense, dear.
Okay, you yelled at me for no reason.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
know how he gets you guys we're wrong oh talk to the mom about the baby wrong wrong wrong
try saying it you're all talk to mom again maybe if i say sister sit up sister sister sh you'll wake her i just put her down to sleep if she wakes up she'll just want to eat again is that her food darn it I'm busy, and if you think I'm going to play along with this nonsense,
you're crazier than sparky down at the firehouse.
Fine, maybe I am crazy.
I can't rule that out.
Why can't you just help me a little?
Is that too much to ask?
Why are there wasps in the- Uh-oh.
Are you happy?
Poor baby.
There, there.
Did your brother scare you?
Let me see.
Ah!
It was a snap!
Oh my god.
darn that wasp woman she's a monster that's what she is like it's like emma's paint drawn out of the baby's face wasp woman tets you are promising to hear about this i want you to go to her house right now and give her a piece of my mind okay i don't know where she lives i do Honestly,
you can't miss a house covered with paper nests.
That's so funny.
By the golly, I'll take it up with the PTA.
Or the lodge.
Not the lodge.
What's the PTA?
That's a parent-teacher association, no?
What's the PTA got to do with anything?
Yeah, that's what I'm wondering.
Show some respect, Steve.
The PTA has a lot of cloud in harvest.
Not the cloud.
We run the 1950s cloud.
By gosh, we even have ties to the lodge.
I think I've asked the other annual blood drive annual blood drive huh wait that was new how much blood we get you'd be more impressed donations are mandatory Steve if you're still here come Sunday you'll be expected to give what do you mean until I'm still here until it hurts even Hank will have to donate of course lodge members are exempt remember that hey either way no one's sticking me with the needle i'm not good with needles you guys we don't use needles i'm leaving don't forget to put the papers out for jimmy you know how he gets i kind of want to fight jimmy again i kind of want to punch everybody now wait can i do that hold on let's save over jimmy jimmy james is going to make me violent okay hold on come here mom
won't let me dang okay i can't believe i can fight jimmy james what did jimmy ever do to you this guy is a menace what are you talking about hey yeah i did whoa that what could you you know uh take the sneakers see you see you later and then let's also give him the newspaper hey steve okay now we say Wait,
I can use the arrow keys to move also?
You're right!
Oh my gosh!
Searching the body!
You find a key and a gun!
I think I...
I can't...
I killed Jimmy James!
Oh my god!
Oh, I got sent to jail.
Um, hello?
Boy, in Harvest, you can't just go around killing little children in public.
You're under arrest for murder in the first degree.
Come with me.
This is your first arrest, Steve.
You just remember, we've got a three strikes, you're out rule here in Harvest.
But you keep your nose clean.
you're here.
Yes, sir.
Does that mean you can kill everyone?
I don't know.
Oh, he's tucking me in.
Tete, tete.
Amazing.
That's why you're the best boss.
Great job.
It's literally the meme.
Bless your ghostly soul, Mitt, for braving yourself to go on this acid trip that is Harvester.
You will never unsee everything.
Thank you, Philip.
Congrats, Mint, you murderer.
Wait, so I lost a day, but like...
I mean, I lost a day.
But...
Do we still have the god?
Yeah, what's in my...
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to click that.
I do!
And this is the broom closet key.
Wait, I thought he was...
Oh, I was supposed to give him the sneakers.
But he actually didn't give me the closet key.
9mm pistol.
Mom, I killed a child.
Hello, dear.
How are you today?
Bye.
Wait, let me type in Jimmy James.
Jimmy.
Stop speaking nonsense, dear.
We don't know a Jimmy here.
Don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy.
You know how he gets.
They don't know.
I've never actually seen Jimmy different.
Good job!
He's on here!
Jimmy hoo!
Okay, so we have the thing with the missile base where they want me to talk to...
Or they want me to investigate the firehouse.
I have only gone to the...
I only want to go to the meat plant when it's like absolutely necessary.
so...
I really don't want to do it right now.
Who's Jimmy James?
But what else?
Oh, we have the broom closet key now?
I guess let's go to the fire station.
Oh, and the wasp lady.
Actually, let's go to the top wasp lady first.
Yeah, Wasp Lady for my mom.
You should show your brother.
It's so horrible.
Ta-ta!
It's not often that I get visitors.
My...
Oh.
Uh...
Mom.
A triviality.
Okay, I guess I can't talk to her then.
Is there anything I can show her?
The pistol I can show her.
my gun.
Attack her?
Take her out?
Okay.
Death of Jimmy James arc starting.
I'm fed she's gonna attack me with the bees.
Wait, I can't get behind her.
Wait, I can get in front of her.
What is What's she eating?
Wait, why can't I get around her now?
Wait, what is it?
Right click to...
There was something... I guess...
Oh, right click to arm disarm.
I have no bullets!
Oh, no.
No!
Maybe?
Okay, well that's good to know that we don't have any bullets because then...
What if I actually tried to use it for real?
God damn it, Jimmy.
Thought I saw something pop up.
Examine the fence.
Oh, the pickets of the fence gleam with a fresh coat of white paint.
the clean-cut soldiers standing at attention defending truth justice in the American way I'm
back wow you guys are still painting hello Steve lovely day isn't it still sketching the same nude man I see that's what I'm saying it's been two days once you find a perfect model you don't let it insert that one meme song watch my nine millimeter go bang why did I dying wait um what do I need to maybe i talked to this guy instead bye bye bye wait stop it you're messing me up okay i don't converse on okay
that's two things
uh what was the guy's name you're messing me up what was the guy's name that asked me to
Asked me to talk to them.
No, not Jimmy James.
Do you guys know Jimmy James?
Come again?
Oh, nobody remembers him.
Boyle, is that his name?
Oh, Buster Monroe?
Yeah, yeah.
Will, thank you so much for the thank you.
Buster Mun...
Oh my goodness, Ro.
Come again?
No.
Okay, bye.
Bye-bye.
I guess I'll go hide in the broom closet.
Which I don't really want to do, but...
Which one's the broom closet?
Oh, here.
I don't necessarily want to do this.
Wait, take a picture!
oh you're busted what screwing in the school broom closet what will people think are you blackmailing us you little shit calm down mr.
Harrell Stephen would never do that he's a smiley bear but we should give him a token of our appreciation for his silence here Stephen take this baseball bat you'll find it quite useful
I think this photo is worth more than that more than that you won't get we don't have much money we're educators not janitors now will you take the bat or not okay wise decision Stephen take the bat look at they're still kissing him they probably yeah they really took it wait Now I have another weapon.
What do you guys...
You guys are just gonna...
The...
It's...
What's the...
There's...
A glass protected fire.
I don't think there's anything else that I can go into.
Oh, okay.
Take another photo?
Yeah, you're so right.
Well, that didn't work.
Aw, man.
Okay.
Well...
I got a bat, but I'm not quite sure what to use it for?
Uh...
Let's see, post office, general store...
Who do I get to beat up?
I'm actually kind of stuck now since...
You use it for Jimmy normally.
Wait, really?
Higurashi.
I killed Jimmy with the bat.
Ah!
You're the task from the lodge.
Oh, is that what I'm supposed to do?
Okay, thank you.
Use it on Jimmy James' corpse.
I take it you wish to be initiated into the mysteries of the Order of the Cross.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I want to know what you know.
know then that securing the application was but the first step on your road to enlightenment oh my god oh my god you must complete a series of tasks to prove your worthiness as an initiate okay what kind of tasks what kind of tasks minor pranks more tests of wit than prowess but to complete them you must if you wish to enter these walls minor prank a i'll bet what have you got minor prank there is in harvest a man named mr johnson oh yeah yeah yeah he owns a tucker pride and joy i should like you to put a scratch in it a scratch that's all as i said a minor prank mind you you're not to damage the vehicle single scratch and welcome the membership thank you return here and i shall give you your next task scratch do i key his car okay that's a crime actually it's not a prank that is a crime but um okay
scratch Uh, wait, no, no.
Oh, I was about to say, where is it taking me?
Um, do I key his car?
Hey, what the hell are you doing?
Stay out of there.
How do I get Mr. Tucker to leave?
Maybe, hold on, let's see.
I have any, oh, the gun.
Let's kill him.
Okay, hold on.
Walk this way.
No.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
One step forward.
Oh.
I just left.
Ah.
Make him leave permanently.
He goes to the diner.
He does.
but maybe we have to wait for when uh boy he is here sheriff dwayne dwayne dwayne i never conduct business over lunch catch me at my office later okay bye stop on by anytime steve i can't talk now the dishes are okay bye nobody wants to talk to me anymore stop by anytime steve okay all right bye not even the kid wants to talk to me nobody wants to talk to me i gotta get rid of dwayne how do we do that i don't
want to talk to deputy lubis kiddo you brought me any of them girly picture books no sorry oh heck why should you be any different from the sheriff or Mrs. Loomis.
Why did he say his wife's name like that?
I'd be right applied if you could just see Claire to bringing me just one of them books.
Believe me, it'll be worth your time to do it.
You want another one?
I...
Get a time, kiddo.
They're a whole quarter, mister.
I don't have that money just lying around.
Come on!
I wonder if they've restocked them though.
For my own.
Wait, this is all cleaned up now.
L-L-Lumis has loose lips?
The guy I was just talking to?
Aw man, nothing else.
Ah.
Wait, oh, exit.
Um...
Hello, Steve.
Hi.
Tell you to buy anything today?
Uh, no thanks.
I don't have any money.
Okay, dear.
You check back if you decide there's anything you want.
I'll be happy to help you.
Come back soon.
Who is...
This is Mrs. Phelps.
I don't know how to make the day pass, though.
My house.
Where does even this guy live?
He talks about his wife.
but he's where does he live of mysterious I'm a little lost might be time to bust out the walkthrough Stephanie yeah we haven't seen her in a bit no thank you so much for the 50 gift thank you holy cow thank you thank you oh my gosh thank you this place is so bizarre The alien music.
Steve, I'm so glad you came back.
What have you been doing?
Murdering children.
I visited the lodge.
Oh.
Talked to the sergeant-at-arms there.
He knows that there's something out of whack here.
He told me if I wanted to find out what it is, I should join the lodge.
I've decided to join the lodge, Stephanie.
Uh-oh.
I think the answer to all our questions is inside.
That place...
It's so sinister.
Maybe, but I've got to join anyway.
You may be playing right into their hands.
Did you think of that?
Doesn't it seem like you're being herded toward the lodge?
That's one of the things I hope to find out.
I hope finding out doesn't get you killed.
Come back and visit me soon, okay?
She's so cute.
Um, she has nice taste.
That's so funny.
Yeah, she's got nice taste.
Uh, kiss her?
Can I?
I'm going to ask her if I can kiss her.
Excuse me.
Wait, I'm going to save in case she shoots me.
Just like Jimmy James.
I'm glad to see you.
I feel so alone, cooped up in here.
You're not making sense.
Stephanie!
Bye!
Come back and visit me soon, okay?
I was supposed to be sad with the music, but then it got all whimsical.
Stephanie, why won't you let me...
Press my lips against your mouth!
Why?
cruel world.
I'm going to join the lodge and I'm never going to look back!
She's wearing the same thing as two days ago.
Just wanted to see if it still worked.
Hold on.
I'm going to look up a walkthrough.
I just had my friend message me.
Well, it was a couple hours ago.
I didn't see it.
But if they were like OMG, Harvester!
Uh, walkthrough...
Wait, Harvester walkthrough.
Uh, let's see.
Open up.
Okay.
Uh...
Scratch Mr. Johnson's car.
Go to the post office and use the what wait what the aura lube on the manhole kid what at the post wait I think I missed something Huh?
What?
Huh?
Wait
Oh wait this is not the right way out how do I get out of your house this way so we're going to the post office this says day two but it's actually day three for us because I lost a day due to murder my bad
go to the post office and use the aura lube on the manhole oh this right here manhole key is stuck at the top of the manhole cover oh wait where do I get Where was that?
Oh, the there's oh back at the okay, I see so I missed At the pot stem house In the medicine cabinet.
I tried opening it though Maybe maybe it was one of those things where oh yeah, see I Examined it and then I forgot to open it.
Ah Got a headache this aspirin could do the trick Oralube!
A jar of extra strength oralube.
Great for getting in and out of tight spots.
Take that.
Cough medicine.
One hour cough medicine.
Yeast disinfectant.
Tonight.
Not to be used for baking cookies.
Toothpaste.
Be sure to roll up the tube from the bottom.
Tampons.
Better ask Stephanie about these.
I don't know nothing about that.
18-year-old boy.
Vitamins.
New zippy vitamins will pick you up.
Floss.
Dental floss.
300 yards of it.
Band-aids.
Shouldn't they be called bandages?
Uh-oh.
You guys are gonna get sued.
Stephanie, teach this guy about tampons!
Okay, now we can go back to the post office.
Wait, should we...
Should we go ask her?
I mean, I guess we might.
Might as well.
Alright, let's use the lube.
I should loosen it up a bit.
Slimy manhole key.
I got it.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, wait.
I think...
Oh, oops.
Wait.
Ah, it's okay, probably.
Manhole.
There we go.
If it becomes night now, Nightfall descends upon harvest.
Oh, okay, okay.
This is fine.
We don't have to ask her.
It's kind of, you know.
All right.
Time to go to the Johnson residence.
A manhole cover is locked in place.
Nasty stench drifts up from the sewers below.
Oh wait Maybe I go back to the Hold on Maybe I go Wait Do I go Through the manhole
Uh Damn it Damn it I love how it says Use manhole key on It's so mysterious
It's pranking time We're gonna do a little prank Hey guys Welcome back to my channel Today Hey, I'm pranking this guy, my neighbor, Mr. Johnson.
Oh, here we go, okay.
Small passageway leads into the sewers.
Here we go.
The coat of moisture has formed along the surface of the wheel valve.
We go...
We are in here.
And we're...
Oh, rusted grate.
Do I...
use more okay I used it uh what's this oh there's a sealed wall small section of the wall has been resealed due to water damage what else is in my inventory oh
man well that didn't work corroded wall there's a tiny indentation in the concrete yeah maybe the shovel Aha!
This is the sneaky music, everybody.
Where is...
Okay.
Is making my way through...
The underground.
Okay.
Cool.
Making my way!
Empty oil cans litter the floor.
Large oil pan filled with with lugs and bolts.
Oh, we're in, we're in, we're in.
Pitchfork.
An old rusty pitchfork.
I'll take that.
Yeah, thank you.
The window has been bricked up and sealed off.
All right.
Mr. Johnson has a myriad of goodies on his tool bench.
What did he got on there?
Tucker, Tucker, Tucker, Tucker.
Tucker, Texas.
Gas can.
This gas can is a similar model to the Postmaster's gas can.
I mean, I can't imagine there's so many, eh?
The heavily used tools sharpener and sander.
Not the only thing.
The window is what?
Flashlight.
Missing batteries.
Yeah, but it might come in handy.
Rubber mallet.
Useful for gophers?
Poster.
A faded poster is a 1948 sexiest tomboy award!
Wait, Mr. Johnson might have great taste.
Wait, wait, Mr. Johnson?
He might have amazing taste.
How many license plates does Mr. Johnson need for October in one year?
The annual blood drive has been mark down for the upcoming Saturday.
I thought it was Sunday.
The carrying case is filled with nothing but lint and sawdust.
Is there anything here?
Oh.
Eched in the side.
Oh, sorry.
I'm covering it, but there's a blow torch.
Reads thinking of you, Edna.
Wait.
Eched in the side of the blow torch reads thinking of you, Edna.
What does that mean?
Wait, what the hell does that mean?
How do I get out of it?
Oh, exit.
Garbage bags are piled up against the wall.
Do I now use the key?
I wonder if it's a sword.
Use broom closet key.
Did it.
There was nothing else on the tool bench.
Okay, bye.
Yeah, that was not a mine.
They said don't hurt the car.
That was kind of insane.
La la la.
So we back in the mine swinging our pickaxe from side to side.
Can I recover the manhole?
No?
He's gonna know.
Get pranked!
Mr. Johnson!
Wait, it's nighttime.
This is kind of exciting, no?
Wait, hold on.
Before we go anywhere.
I think I can save over this one.
Well, I don't know.
I'm scared.
Pranked.
Okay.
Let's, uh...
Check a couple places.
Let's...
Maybe Edna's diner.
Close!
What do you mean, closed?
The diner is locked up.
What do you mean by that?
The cemetery?
Yeah, we can go to the cemetery.
Spooky!
Mr. Podstum.
What are you doing here?
What are you doing here at this hour, Mr. Potsdam?
Potsdam.
I'm burying our cat.
She passed away, and I'm burying her.
Go away and mind your own business.
Then, where's the cat?
I left her at home.
Now leave me alone!
This kind of stuff can come back to haunt you.
Matches.
Matches prepared especially for your...
Wedding.
Potsdam.
Isn't this the Potsdam crypt?
Yeah.
What is he doing here?
V and y'all, welcome back to Vembership, thank you.
Thank you.
Hmm.
Do you still have the gas?
I don't think so.
No.
Let's see, where else can we go?
Um, the TV station maybe?
Can we go inside?
The TV station is closed.
I thought someone said I missed something, but I don't know from where.
Do you walk like the guy in the game IRL?
Absolutely.
The meat plant only has day shifts.
There's so many cats around here.
Why does it have to...
I hate...
I was like, okay, you can be as stupid and you can be as vulgar and you can be as edgy as you want, but just leave the animals out of it.
It's my only thing.
I don't care about your dark humor.
Just leave the animals out.
It's not one thing that annoys me about horror games is when they do stuff to the pets.
Yeah.
Let's see.
I imagine everything else will be closed.
I'll go back here and see if there was anything, though.
I really thought I got everything, but I'll double check.
Johnson's, apparently.
Okay.
Let's see.
Zam and the bags.
A dolly.
This dolly might be useful after the wedding.
Oh, okay.
We're just...
Just stealing that.
Yeah, I think I need that for the wedding.
Oh, I'll double check the guide if there's anything else too.
Um...
Oh, let's see.
Uh...
And the pitchfork.
Oh, take a screwdriver.
Oh, it's telling me to use the screwdriver on the car.
Oh!
But I use the key instead!
I was I was resourceful with my with oh okay okay well we'll take it just in case I need it later okay anyway I think we can go tell them that we did the scratching you can key it with any key it's smart never knew that yeah that's such a because you know when I think of like keying a car like that's why I figured the key would be the thing to use it with that's so fun must be for those who don't have the key yet probably that's a nice way to know i've heard that this game can like soft lock you so i guess that's one of the ways that they attempted to not soft lock you garbage person welcome to membership thank you so you have completed your first task now that you've scratched the tucker you may proceed to your second task you will steal a bolt of fabric from the fireman and bring it to be fabric the lodge is comprised of thieves okay I don't need a novel to pigeonhole that it exerts control over is
not a fact whatever you may think of the order is only speculation You just talk so slowly.
Is this the Thieves Guild?
Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
The decaying corpse that is your memory.
You'll be back.
The only answer for you is here, Steven.
Okay.
Don't forget that.
He sounds like a...
I'm trying to do my demon voice.
Steven, the only place for you is here, Steven.
No, no, not again.
Oh!
I'm saving you guys!
The shirtless...
Ah!
It's pouring.
The old man is snowing.
I love the burger.
The burger is the absolute best part.
Hold the pepperoni.
We're not body shaming here.
It's just not what I want to see at the moment.
Let's see.
Well, guys, I think I'm gonna call it here.
I think we'll call it here.
Pepperoni.
Um...
This game is, uh...
Well...
This game is a fever dream.
What's the burger all about?
This game is bananas.
I don't understand what's going on at all.
But I'm here for the ride.
I'm here to experience something that I felt I have never experienced in life or after life.
It is a game.
I'm going to spoil myself a little bit.
reading ahead but oh wow okay okay i just wanted to see how many days there were okay and we're on well i guess we're on day three no it gets insane i'm very excited for that i'm very excited for that hot dog hamburger thanks for the quality time don't say that Thank you,
SleeperDiam.
How many are there?
There's six days.
And...
So most violent adventure game of all time, you say.
Mostly been crimes against decency.
Quality time.
Yeah, I'm excited to see the more...
See what happens there.
But...
Are you playing with the sensor on?
I...
Part of me says yes.
Part of me says...
You know...
Yes, it's real people, but it's also special effects, so I'm kind of like...
Hmm...
I don't know yet.
I will remember Jimmy.
Jimmy James.
Oh wait, you mean like sensor in the game?
Oh no, I don't have that.
I have sensor.
I have this sensor.
Which we really didn't even need.
Thank you for playing these older games.
Yeah, thank you, Andy.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, kind of missed we didn't have more time with Jimmy, but whatever.
Whatever.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the redirect!
We were about to end this.
though let's see if there's anybody who can i read direct to let's see let's see
redirect to i always oh my gosh ever since i ever since i subscribed to tokusatsu my whole like thing is all them
I think we'll just end it.
It's okay.
Yeah.
I just see Toku Shao Tzu.
Toku Shao Tzu!
They are like, they air the episodes of the new Common Rider and the older Common Rider too.
Which I have to, I am, I am behind on a couple episodes so I have to, I have to, I have to catch up.
But anyways, thank you guys so much for hanging out with me.
lot of fun and very wacky and something very something thank you guys thank you thank you i will see you guys when i see you next and yeah what's a meet oh it's a meet oh bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye thank you see you eat that i shy bye